bien bonjour à tous on va laisser les
les sénateurs arriver tranquillement
après leur petit déjeuner terminé c'est
important pour commencer la la
journée en sachant aussi que beaucoup
beaucoup sont sont peut-être déjà
reparti chez eux en ce moment nous
étudions le projet de loi de finan au
Sénat et c'est un vrai parcours du
combattant croyez-moi on a fini hier
soir les 2250 amendements à minuit et là
on recommence sur l'émission donc ça
fait 3 semaines très très
chargé Monsieur le Conseiller Mesdames
et Messieurs chers collègues l'agression
russe de l'Ukraine en février 2022 a
bouleversé le cours de l'Histoire
l'histoire de l'Ukraine bien sûr mais
aussi l'histoire de la construction
européenne immédiatement solidaire de
l'Ukraine l'Union européenne s'est senti
directement attaqué l'appartenance de
l'Ukraine à la famille européenne a
semblé s'imposer si bien que le Conseil
européen a répondu positivement à la
demande d'intégration de l'Ukraine dans
l'Union en lui reconnaissant
officiellement le statut de candidat en
juin dernier ainsi qu'à la Moldavie j'en
profite pour saluer la présence de Nadia
sologou qui est présidente du groupe
d'amitié France France Ukraine notre
commission a donc engagé un travail de
réflexion sur ce nouvel élargissement à
l'Est qu'envisage l'Union européenne
notre table ronde de ce matin vise à
informer les sénateurs sur la phase
décisive où nous sommes après la récente
publication le wi novembre du paquet
élargissement de la Commission
européenne qui recommande d'aller de
l'avant et à 2 semaines du prochain
Conseil européen qui devra décider ou
non de suivre ces recommandations de la
commission je rappelle que nous avons
auditionné à cette même date du 8
novembre la secrétaire d'État Laurence
bon dès le lendemain le Commissaire
européen en charge de
l'élargissement et enfin la semaine
dernière les rapporteurs du groupe
d'experts franco-allemands d' groupe des
12 sur des réformes qui pourraient
permettre à à l'Union européenne
d'absorber de nouveaux membres dans les
meilleures conditions
possibles Monsieur le Conseiller nous
vous remercions de représenter ici
l'ambassadeur d'Ukraine à Paris monsieur
Vadim Omelchenko que nous connaissons
bien et qui est malheureusement retenu
par des engagements antérieur impératif
et je crois vous m'avez dit qu'il était
à Strasbourg ce matin avant de vous
donner la parole dans un instant pour un
exposé liminaire de quelques minutes
permettez-moi de présenter brièvement
les autres participants de cette table
ronde que je remercie de leur présence
et de vous indiquer le déroulé de nos
échanges qui concerneront l'Ukraine en
premier lieu puis la Moldavie pays
officiellement candidat et enfin la
geéorgie pays auquel la Commission
propose que soit reconnu ce statut de
candidat en décembre tout d'abord
monsieur Jean-Dominique guuliani
familier du Sénat qui préside la
Fondation Robert Schumann centre
européen de référence pour la
construction européenne qui fait vivre
l'esprit de son père
fondateur tout en restant constamment
attentif aux évolutions du monde de
l'Union européenne et de chacun des pays
qui la compose ou l'entoure il voz je
vous l'avais dit que nos sénateurs
terminaient leur petit
déjeuner il publie chaque année un
précieux Atlas permanent de l'Union
européenne et il a pris récemment
position sur l'élargissement dans une
tribune remarquée dont je partage
l'essentiel des constats courageux
Monsieur Thierry Chupin conseiller
spécial l'une des tête pensante de
l'Institut Jacques Delor autre SIG tank
essentiel pour la réflexion sur l'Union
européenne et son évolution spécialiste
de la prospective politique il est
l'auteur notamment d'un ouvrage marquant
publié en 2015 qui n'a hélas pas perdu
de son actualité intitulé la fracture
politique de l'Europe et sous-titré
crise de légitimité et déficit politique
lui aussi habitué de la maison monsieur
Lucas matchek est un chercheur et
enseignant spécialiste des pays d'Europe
central et oriental et dir dirige le
campus de Scien pot Paris à Dijon il est
l'auteur notamment d'un ouvrage de
référence publié il y a une douzaine
d'années qui est intitulé
l'élargissement met-il en péril le
projet européen c'est la question qu'on
se pose tous les matins en se réveillant
qui fait admirablement le point sur les
leçons à tirées du grand élargissement
de 2004 et qui mériterait sans doute un
retirage et une mise à jour avec ou sans
le même titre prémonitoire ou non mais
comme je vous le dis tous les matins en
se réveillant on y pense il nous le dira
peut-être monsieur Florent
martiac qui est un spécialiste reconnu
de l'Europe orientale et de
l'élargissement auteur lui de nombreux
articles sur ces sujets en particulier
dans le rapport annuel ramsè et dans la
revue Politique étrangère chercheur à
l'Institut français des relations
internationales et au centre
franco-autrichien pour le rapprochement
de l'Europe il nous apportera sans doute
le regard croisé de notre partenaire
autrichien et plus généralement des pays
d' Europe centrale sur ces questions
madame la docteure éléonora polily nous
vient de Rome où elle est chercheure à
l'Institut des affaires internationales
et au Centre d'études politiques
européennes et a publié plusieurs
articles récents sur l'élargissement
bien qu'elle parle français et anglais
je suis heureux que nous ayons pu lui
proposer de s'exprimer dans sa langue
maternelle car nous tenons ici à
défendre la diversité linguistique
inhérente à la construction européenne
et c'est un point sur lequel j'insiste
souvent enfin je dois excuser Michel
vigel qui est correspondante de
frankfourter
algemitung à Paris et qui devait nous
apporter son regard d'outrerin mais se
trouve HL souffrante nous lui souhaitons
donc un prompte rtablissement et j'ai pu
accompagner la semaine dernière le
président Gérard Larcher en Allemagne et
percevoir que nos amis allemands
partagent avec nous la conviction que
l'élargissement et la réforme de l'Union
européenne doivent aller de
paire ce que je vous propose donc je je
refixe les règles de l'exercice hein qui
qui durent sur 3h donc avec trois trois
trois pays différ 2h3 pardon je voz je
suis déjà rappelé à l'ordre je voulais
m'étendre mais qui dure 2h3 donc nous
donnons 3 45 à 50 minutes par séquence
nous laissons donc euh l'ambassadeur ou
son représentant s'exprimé pour à peu
près 5 minutes après je vous propose
chacun pour 2 minutes ou 3 de nous
donner votre votre avis soit sur le le
l'exposé de de l'ambassadeur ou de son
représentant soit éventuellement lui
poser une question et puis après je
laisse la parole à mes sénateurs et nous
pourrons faire un commentaire pour pour
terminer nous avons préféré séquencer de
cette façonlà plutôt que d'avoir tout le
monde en même temps ça laisse libre
parole à chaque à chaque état de
s'exprimer librement sans sans
contrainte et sans dialogue retenu si si
nécessaire monsieur le conseiller et
c'est à vous merci monsieur le
président madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs chers amis tout
d'abord je voudrais exprimer mes nos
remerciement pour le soutien puissant
que vous le Sénat et la France apporé à
l'Ukraine dans les conditions
d'agression à grande échelle terrible
brutal de la fédération de de Russie
nous ressentons constamment le soutien
important et vital que la France apporte
à l'Ukraine espérant sa poursuite
jusqu'à notre victoire totale sur
l'agresseur nous l'apprécions vivement
et sommes sincèrement reconnaissants
pour toute aide et l'assistance
militaire que la France apporte aux
forces de sécurité et de défense
ukrainien afin de prévenir une menace
réelle pour la paix sur le continent et
dans le monde dans son ensemble nous
comptons sur votre soutien continue à
l'Ukraine sur la voie de l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne et sur vos vos
encouragements aux États de l'Union
européenne à entamer des négociations de
de l'adhésion avec
l'Ukraine je tiens à souligner que la
position ferme et claire de la France a
jouer un rôle important dans le soutien
des États membres de l'Union européenne
à l'roit à à l'Ukraine le statut de pays
candidat nous l'apprécions vraiment cela
nous sommes bien conscients que
l'adhésion à l'Union Européen c'est un
processus
difficile nous savons que nous devons
faire et nous avançons le plus vite
possible mais l'adhésion de l'union de
l'ukrain à l'Union Européen est aussi un
catalyseur pour pour une Europe plus
forte et plus et plus
sûre rapport récent reconnaissant un
progrès remarquable pour de l'Ukraine
constitue une étape clé pour ouvrir la
voie aux négociations de l'union de
l'adhésion à l'Union européen cette
décision constitue non seulement une
reconnaissance des de l'engagement
inbranlable de l'Ukraine envers les
valeurs européens mais également un
impératif stratégique pour la sécurité
et la prospérité de l'Union Européen
l'Ukraine a fait preuve d'une
détermination sans faille dans dans sa
poursuite de l'intégration européen face
à l'agression militaire russe à grande
échelle malgré les énormes difficultés
l'Ukraine
suit les SEP recommandations de la
commission européen atteignant en niveau
un niveau euh d'achevvement
extraordinaire cet engagement
inébranlable en faveur des des réformes
soulligne la volonté de l'Ukraine
d'accepter les normes et les valeurs de
l'Union européenne l'Ukraine a
intensifié ses efforts ces dernières
semaines le gouvernement a présenter en
première lecture des lois qui renforcent
sa capacité institutionnelle du bureau
national de lutte contre la corruption
et augmente sa compétence de l'Agence
pour la prévention de la corruption des
modifications législatives sur les
minorités nationales qui sera adopté par
le Parlement européen la semaine
prochaine l'Ukraine a rempli ses
obligations et il est désormais temps
pour le Conseil européen à agir la
manière à la manière décisive l'Union
Européen doit être uni dans son soutien
à la demande d'adhésion de de l'Ukraine
non seulement comme le témoignage des
progrès significatifs de l'Ukraine mais
aussi comme symbole de la solidarité
européen face à l'agression l'adhésion
de l'Ukraine à l'Union Européen
renforcera non seulement la la puissance
politique et économique de l'Union mais
renforcera également sa sécurité le
potentiel de l'Ukraine
contribuera au au Pact ver vert européen
au riseseau trans-européen à la
cybersécurité et la sécurité alimentaire
en outre l'adhésion de l'union de
l'Ukraine constituera une l'heure de
l'espoir pour pour les autres pays
aspirant à la démocratie démontrant que
l'Union Européen reste un fervant
défenseur des valeurs des valeurs
démocratiques l'Ukraine c'est
l'Europe c'est pour cette idée que
l'Ukraine se bat aujourd'hui et c'est
pour pour elle que nous nous devons
gagner ensemble notre désir de liberté
nos valeurs démocratiques européen
commune nous nous ont donné le courage
et la volonté de louter nous avons
également la volonté de changer pour le
mieux l'Ukraine est en en train d'écrire
sa nouvelle histoire et elle a le droit
de déterminer s propre son propre avenir
notre définition est simple l'Ukraine
n'accepte pas de jouer le rôle des
colonies russes ou des Z tampons entre
la Russie et l'Europe nous faisons
partie d'un monde européen libre et
égalitaire dans lequel les citoyens
eux-mêmes choisissent le gouvernement le
gouvernement s'efforce à d'améliorer la
vie de ceux qui l'ont choisi mais ce
gouvernement est ensuite
démocratiquement
changé dans dans un discours prononcé
forum stratégique de Bled en Slovénie en
août dernier le président du Conseil
européen Charles Michel a affirmé la
nécessité pour l'Union européenne de
renforcer ses liens et devenir plus
puissant pour relever le défi de
l'arrgissement élargissement et
précisant que l'Europe devrait être
prête d'ici 2030 en acceptant des
nouveaux des nouveaux membres l'Union
Européen renforcera son rôle de
puissance mondiale et
contribuera à la sécurité et la
stabilité globale de l'Europe en
développant les des relations étroites
avec l'Ukraine et d'autres pays
candidats l'Union Européen peut
travailler ensemble pour relever les
défis de sécurité régionale contribuant
ainsi à la stabilité et la paix en
Europe l'évolution de l'Ukraine vers
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne grâce à
la à la réponse héroïque de des
Ukrainiens à l'invasion à grande échelle
de la R ai à apportter une nouvelle
dynamique au processus d'é
élargissement nous avons aujourd'hui une
occasion unique de relancer le processus
d'expansion d'expansion et de restaurer
la confi la confiance en Lui c'est dans
l'intérêt de tous les candidats dont
certains attendent à l'pport de l'Union
Européen depuis des décennies cependant
nous ne pouvons transformer l'histoire
de l'élargiss en une histoire positive
qu'ensemble l'Ukraine la Moldavie et les
les pays des Balcans occidentaux
l'expérience de ces dernières dernières
années montre que le progrès de
l'Ukraine constitue un puissant moteur
des progrès pour les autres pays
candidats le progrès de l'Ukraine
contribue à mobiliser et à consolider le
soutien au processus
d'élargissement au de même l'Union
européenne continue des progrès
significatifs réalisés par l'Ukraine
dans dans la mise en de la mise en œuvre
des SEP
recommandations de la commission
européen en seulement 16 mois reconnu
par le paquet d'élargissement de l'Union
européenne du 8 novembre 2023 nous
attendons une décision
politique du Conseil européen d'entamer
des négociations d'adhésion avec
l'Ukraine lors de sa réunion le 14 et 15
décembre nous comprenons clairement que
nous ne sommes pas que au début du
chemin vers l'adhésion à part un tiers à
l'Union Européen et que nous sommes
déterminés à poursuivre les
transformations aujourd'hui l'Ukraine
l'Europe ont absolument besoin l'une de
l'autre il s'agit des rétablissement de
la justice historique et un accord
gagnant gagnant merci beaucoup merci
monsieur chisi
pardon merci Monsieur schwiiski Je je
retrouve en vos propos et m'en son
témoins Didier Marie et Claude Kerne les
propos fort tenu par Ivana cllimush qui
est votre représentante auprès de
l'Union européenne nous revenons de
Madrid où c'était la la séance de
annuelle de de la coszak
et semestrielle pardon de la coszak et
et donc elle avait ses ses propos très
forts qu'elle a à chaque fois d'ailleurs
mais j'ai trouvé cette cette année sur
un discours on avait l'impression de de
relancement parce que on a l'impression
que que ce conflit entre dans la routine
du quotidien et et donc qu'il est
important de temps en temps de rappeler
à la fois les les valeurs pour
lesquelles les Ukrainiens se battent et
et qu'ils sont et qu'ils sont aux
frontières de l'Union européenne tel que
nous l'entendons aujourd'hui je passe la
parole aux experts donc je le rappelle
pour quelques minutes soit sous forme de
de d'analyse de ce qui a été dit soit
sous forme de de question monsieur
guolani à vous monsieur le Président
Madame et messieurs les sénateurs merci
beaucoup de de votre invitation je
voudrais dire combien
euh l'attitude de la Russie interpelle
non seulement l'Union européenne à ses
frontières mais aussi l'ensemble de la
Communauté des États du monde en réalité
en libérant euh un certain nombre de
ressentiments qui se peuvent se traduire
partout en conflit du Kabak jusqu'au
Venezuela qui s'apprête à attaquer son
voisin le
Guyana désormais comme un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité
s'autorise à violer la Charte de l'ONU
et les traités tout est possible
deuxième élément que je voudrais
rappeler c'est que donc pour la France
et pour l'Union
européenne si nos amis ukrainiens su
faire obstacle à l'agression russe ils
ne pourront pas gagner seuls et c'est à
nous de les aider à faire échec à cet
impérialisme russe qui peut remettre en
cause l'existence même d'une Union
européenne traversée par des ethnies des
religions des minorités tellement
différentes que pour garder et préserver
l'unité de l'Union européenne nous
devons faire échec absolument à cette
politique russe qui pose le problème de
la politique française à l'égard de la
Russie qui me paraît devoir être un peu
plus clair et un peu plus ferme que ce
qu'elle a été jusqu'à maintenant dernier
point je voudrais rappeler mettre
l'accent sur ce que dit Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur l'élargissement je préfère
parler pour ma part d'intégration nos
amis anglo-saxons parle d'expansion de
l'Europe donc
l'intégration de l'Ukraine de la
Moldavie et d'autres de nos voisins
c'est d'abord le choix des peuples ce
n'est pas un complot
de
diplomates qui voudrai élargir l'Union
européenne c'est le choix des peuples de
l'Ukraine et c'est les Ukrainiens qui
ont choisi de vouloir se rapprocher et
intégrer l'Union européenne et dernier
point je voudrais dire combien dans
cette période difficile nous devons
faire preuve d'optimisme car je connais
bien l'Ukraine notre fondation a
longtemps travaillé je pense que son
intégration dans l'Union européenne bien
sûr il y a des conditions à remplir vous
l'avez rappelé Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
c'est un grand coup de jeûe pour l'Union
européenne et pour ses politiques
évidemment je seraai intarissable sur le
sujet si j'en avais le temps monsieur le
Président mais je ne pense pas qu'il
soit nécessaire de modifier les traités
je pense que il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire avant pour réussir cette
intégration ensemble et euh acquérir
ainsi vraiment définitivement une
dimension géopolitique que nous
souhaitons pour notre Union
européenne très bien vous n'aviez pas
besoin de plus de temps pour être plus
clair merci Monsieur Julani monsieur
Chopin je je rappelle pour ceux qui ne
le sauraient pas que nous sommes
vidéocaptés donc passons sur le site du
Sénat en direct merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président merci beaucoup monsieur le
conseiller pour pour votre propos euh je
ce que je vais dire effectivement
s'inscrit parfaitement dans ce qui vient
d'être dit par par jeandominque Juliani
peut-être pour ajouter un ou deux
éléments j'étais très sensible à ce que
vous avez dit sur la dimension de
géopolitisation finalement de de
l'Europe induite par par cette invasion
russe de de votre pays et effectivement
cette prise de conscience de la
nécessité de de de de prendre en
considération cette dimension
géopolitique de sécurité ces enjeux
stratégiques euh mettent en en
perspective je crois les les enjeux de
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
de de votre pays à à l'Union européenne
et ça c'est c'est sans doute quelque
chose qui à la fois fait écho à une
dimension un objectif qui était central
dans la construction européenne
elle-même depuis le début de de cette
construction c'est-à-dire cette
construction n'était pas qu'une
construction évidemment visant à à créer
un marché visant à créer une communauté
de droit
le marché cette communauté de droit éant
des instruments pour répondre en fait à
des enjeux géopolitiques de
réconciliation de pacification
d'extension de de l'espace de paix et de
sécurité sur sur le continent je crois
que la la nouvelle rupture géopolitique
introduite depuis 24 février 2022 euh
pose dans des dans des termes
effectivement renouveler cette cette
question euh de de l'élargissement
effectivement comme comme processus
d'intégration euh et l'issu de de de
cette guerre dans dans votre pays mais
aussi l'issue de de ce processus
d'intégration de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne à une échéance qu'il est très
difficile aujourd'hui évidemment de de
mentionner charlesmichel évoqué un
horizon avec cette date de 2030 je crois
qu'il faut être très prudent en fait à
cet égard parce que quand on fixe une
date ça peut nourrir beaucoup de de
déception beaucoup de de de frustration
euh et donc il faut être très prudent à
cet ég mais en tout cas ce qui se joue
c'est évidemment la crédibilité de de de
l'Union européenne du point de vue de de
de cette issue sans doute les les
orateurs qui qui me succéderont
évoqueront la la difficulté que vous
avez vous-même mentionné de ce processus
d'élargissement ou d'intégration de
l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne il y a des leçons sans doute
qui seront attirées des élargissements
précédents et notamment au pays d'Europe
centrale orientale et et Baltique il y a
des enjeux évidemment de renouvellement
de la méthode qui doit être utilisé pour
que cette élargissement puisse être à un
moment donné effectif et puisse être un
un un succès en tout cas c'est ce que
nous espérons tous ici la la deuxième
chose qui m'a frappé en fait dans votre
propos c'est ce que vous avez dit sur la
nécessité de transformer l'histoire de
l'élargissement en une histoire positive
et je pense que vous mettez là le doigt
et l'accent sur une dimension en fait
très importante qui est celle du
discours politique qui doit accompagner
le processus d'élargissement même
renouvelé d'un pays comme l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne et notamment dans un
pays comme la France qui est un pays qui
traditionnellement a un rapport de
défiance aux élargissements tant du
point de vue de ses de son opinion
publique que du point de vue de ses
élites politiques et ça depuis je dirais
les années 70 euh donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez structurel quand on
regarde euh l'évolution du rapport de
l'opinion publique à la perspective
d'adhésion un pays comme l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne on a vu une
amélioration dans le soutien de cette
opinion publique après la Vasion russe
très clairement mais on a vu aussi et
les derniers chiffres de l'Eurobaromètre
2023 de juin 2023 en témoig une baisse
de ce soutien quelques mois plus tard
donc l'opinion publique est très
versatile et je crois que ce que vous
avez dit sur l'importance de ce récit
politique d'accompagnement est
essentiel merci monsieur le Président
merci merci pour l'invitation merci
monsieur le conseiller pour vos discours
alors je m'inscris totalement dans dans
la continuité des deux premiers propos
liminires moi aussi j'étais très
sensible à à notamment deux éléments de
de votre discours c'est-à-dire le fait
qu'au-delà de la dimension symbolique
extrêmement importante et aussi au-delà
d'un appel tout à fait naturel et
légitime à une forme de devoir moral
aussi de de l'Union européenne à l'égard
de l'Ukraine qui qui se bat
effectivement pour des valeurs que que
sont celles de l'Union européenne euh je
pense que c'est très important comme
Thierry Chupin vient de le dire que vous
ayez esquissé un discours positif avec
votre conclusion sur le côté gagnant
gagnant du processus et je pense que
c'est ce type de discours qui faisait
gravement défaut notamment en 2004 et de
manière peut-être encore plus criante
par exemple en 2013 avec avec l'adhésion
de la croe qui pour le coup était une
adhésion totalement inutilisée je dirais
politiquement euh des deux côtés
d'ailleurs euh et
donc je crois que c'est vraiment
important d'insister y compris sur une
dimension d'intérêt très très concret
vous avez parlé de de la sécurité euh de
la sécurité alimentaire et je pense que
c'est vraiment des sujet qu'il faut
qu'il faudra mettre en avant à la fois
du côté des pays candidats mais aussi du
côté des des États-membres pour
convaincre les opinions euh un autre
élément auquel j'étais très sensible
c'est euh
tout ce que vous avez dit sur la
nécessité de procéder ensemble avec les
autres pays candidats parce que je crois
que ce qui est potentiellement ce qui
pourrait être très dommageable pour le
processus est pareil dans les
élargissements précédents c'est un enjeu
de que les pays candidats n'avancent pas
en ordre dispersé ne se ne soit pas dans
une logique de concurrence même si une
Scine émulation entre les pays candidats
est sans doute quelque chose de de tout
à fait utile mais entre émulation et et
et concurrence voire concurrence déloyal
euh il faut il faut savoir tracer la la
frontière et et donc ce que vous avez
dit euh sur ces sur cette DIMENSIONSL me
paraît très très important euh je me
permets du coup puisqu'on é invité à
vous poser aussi des questions euh vous
posez
euh deux peut-être même trois questions
la première
euh finalement si on regarde tous les
élargissements précédents même si on
remonte à à la France du général de
Gaulle euh il y a une constante c'est
que dans un processus d'élargissement il
y a toujours quelques questions
bilatérales qui peuvent bloquer qui
peuvent freiner en 2004 on a eu bon je
viens de la République tchèque les
Tchèques ont eu des sujets mémoriels
avec l'Allemagne ils ont eu des sujets
mémoriels et lié au nucléaire avec
l'Autriche mais l'Italie a eu enfin la
Slovénie a eu quelques sujets avec avec
l'Italie je pourrais
continuer je pense effectivement qu'on
voit clairement aujourd'hui de manière
très con concrète par rapport au Conseil
européen de décembre il y a
potentiellement trois pays membres qui
pourraient poser problème à à
l'unanimité la Hongrie la Slovaquie et
désormais peut-être aussi les Pays-Bas
je vlais vous poser la question s'il y a
une stratégie côté ukrainien de travail
bilatéral notamment par exemple sur les
question mémorielle y compris pour le
coup pour un pays très engagé pour
l'Ukraine que la Pologne mais où on sait
bien que il y a aussi quelques sujets
qui peuvent ressurgir plus tard dans le
processus mais mais très concrètement à
court terme par rapport à des pays
susceptibles de quels sont un peu les
les gestes ou les gages que l'Ukraine
pense
pouvoir mettre en avant pour convaincre
ces pays potentiellement réticents à à
l'ouverture des négociations
euh deuxè question qui qui rebondit sur
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous avez
évoqué cette idée qu'il faut
effectivement que tous les pays candidat
donc j'entends je suppose en incluant
les les Balcans
occidentaux doivent agir de concert doiv
avancer ensemble concrètement est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire là encore est-ce
qu'il y a une stratégie de de travail
avec les pays des Balcans occidentaux je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous que
l'Ukraine a pris quelque part le rôle
d'une forme de
locomotive dans dans ce processus mais
je sens aussi du côté des Balcans
occidentaux beaucoup d'interrogations
voire de frustration d'avoir le
sentiment de d'être entre guillemets
doublé par par l'Ukraine donc est-ce que
vous pourriez développer un tout petit
peu ce point-là et troisème point très
rapidement la question de méthode
effectivement c'est-à-dire est-ce que
vous pensez que la méthode
d'élargissement telle qu'elle ét
pratiquée jusquici est adapté ou quel
est votre point de vue sur la façon de
repenser le processus et les modalités
de processus d'élargissement autour de
toute cette idée de d'intégration
différenciée ou ou adhésion par étap et
cetera merci beaucoup trois questions
très précises et je vous laisserai
répondre après s'il y en avait d'autres
Monsieur
martiac Merci monsieur le
Président alors
effectivement pour faire pour faire
assez court les rapports si on regarde
un petit peu le le le passé et la le
processus d'élargissement la
politiqueélargissement vers les Balcans
il y a y a certains échos qui reviennent
et et les rapports de la Commission on
par le passé souvent été jugé un petit
peu assez peu critique donc ce que ce
que j'essaie de pointer du doigt c'est
qu'il y a deux processus qui sont en
cours en ce moment il y a le processus
qui est celui des réformes l'État de
droit et cetera et puis un processus
politique l'élan politique compte
énormément dans les processus
d'élargissement peu importe les
trajectoires de réformes si l'élan
politique ne peut pas être maintenu
alors on on assiste à un essoufflement
de la politique
d'gissement on a espéré
avec dans que dans les Balcans le
contexte géopolitique relancerait la CE
processusgissement pas été le cas pour
l'instant dans les Balcans et donc ça
soulève un certain nombre de questions
je me joins donc à au commentaire de de
Lucas c'est cette comment comment penser
la politique d'élargissement dans une
vision un peu holistique en en imaginant
que les choses se tiennent les unes avec
les autres et effectivement il y a des
rapports entre le processus
d'élargissement ukrainien et et à l'est
avec celui des Balcans et comment
l'Ukraine peut peser finalement aussi
sur le processus d'élargissement et pas
simplement attendre que l'Union
européenne le le lui propose je pense
qu'il y a des il y a des Mo y pour que
l'Ukraine contribue à cet élan
politique en matière d'élargissement en
identifiant dans le dans le procéus
d'gissement quelles sont les
vulnérabilités européennes que l'Union
européenne a du mal à combler il y en a
une il y en a une très claire qui n'est
pas dans les processus d'élargissement
qui n'est pas sur les processus sur les
ne fait pas partie des des réformes
proposées par le groupe des 12 par les
les les les les les processus d'étape
par com adhésion par étape c'est la
question de la territorialité l'Union
européenne a un malaise à fondamental
qui est lié à son ADN he c'est c'est une
entité postterritoriale par définition
elle a un malaise avec tout ce qui est
territorial de gouver de gouvernance et
de souveraineté territoriale ça pose un
problème dans les Balcans où on a des
situations en Bosnie-Herzégovine au
Kosovo de de souveraineté contestée ça
posera des problèmes demain à l'est que
l'Union européenne aura énormément de
mal à résoudre maintenant du point de
vue ukrainien je jedessus c'est là où
l'Ukraine peut peut un petit peu bouger
les choses si je pe peux me permettre
l'Union européenne dans les Balcans est
bloquée en particulier euh par le le le
le le contentieux entre la Serbie et le
Kosovo c'est plus qu'un contentieux la
Serbie le Kosovo c'est un c'est un
contentieux qui raisonne dans la dans la
dans la région entière c'est un un
contentieux qui par sa par sa son son sa
continuité empêche l'Union européenne
d'avoir une position commune sur un un
point de politique étrangère essentielle
et qui conforte une une autre part la
Serbie euh dans une dans une dans une
mes alliance avec l'Union européenne
vis-à-vis de la Russie ce point
essentiel donc la non reconnaissance du
Kosovo cela est quelque chose qui
ralentit à la fois la géopolitisation de
la politique étrangère de de de de
l'Union européenne vis-à-vis des Balcans
mais ça ralentit
également la possibilité de l'Union
européenne de faire avancer cette
politique de relancer cette politique de
de d'adhésion parce qu'elle se concentre
uniquement sur ce qu'elle pense pouvoir
faire l'État de droit et l'économie en
mettant côté tout ce qui étaitutorité
l'Ukraine je termine làdessus l'Ukraine
en faisant avancer ce sur ce dossier la
reconnaissance du Kosovo mettra un
petit poent faire avancer les choses du
point de vue
européen et et amènerait probablement un
nouveau souffle à à cette à cette
politique d'adhésion alors est-ce qu'il
y a des pensées des réflexions qui qui
vont dans ce sensl dans votre dans votre
pays
merci merci alors madame
poli je je c'est pas vous vous exprimez
finalement en anglais en anglais alors
vous trahissez mon propos
surés sur la diversité
linguistique bon donc traduction sur le
sur le Cano d'accord ok oui
allez-y oui thank you very much merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président
sénateur messieur les ambassadeurs
madame l'ambassadrice c'est un très
grand honneur pour moi d'être ici merci
beaucoup de votre de vos propos
extrêmement intéressant alors si je
comprends bien l'idée générale c'est que
l'Ukraine catalyse sur différents
processus d'une part
l'Ukraine a forgé une voie positive pour
l'élargissement et ça c'est quelque
chose de très nouveau c'est-à-dire la
majorité des citoyens sont pour
l'élargissement par le passé la majorité
était plutôt contre l'idée de
l'élargissement alors les discussions
sur l'élargissement ont été revitalisées
grâce à l'Ukraine d'autre part l'Ukraine
a montré que l'Europe peut devenir un
acteur géopolitique après des années de
critiqu sur le manque de politique
étrangère de l'Union européenne ce qui
se passe en Ukraine montre qu'en fait
l'Union européenne peut en effet devenir
un acteur géopolitique sur la scène
internationale d'autant plus que
aujourd'hui suite à l'invasion de la
Russie en
Ukraine qui a complètement détruit
l'ordre
mondial et bien nous ne vivons plus dans
un ordre mondial où les institutions
international régissent l'ordre mondial
nous vivons dans un contexte régional
c'est pour cela qu'il est
particulièrement important de montrer
aujourd'hui la crédibilité dans ce
processus d'élargissement en permettant
aux pays qui sont à la front de l'Union
européenne de devenir membre et
l'Ukraine peut
également forger permettre de forger une
union plus forte pour des raisons
économiques pour des raisons de sécurité
mais également pour des raisons
politiques ma question est la suivante
est-ce que vous avez un sentiment
interne en interne de quel type d'union
vous souhaitez rejoindre alors on a
beaucoup de débat sur les
réformes et nous sommes conscients fait
un N un nombre de pays sont en faveur de
l'élargissement sur papier en tout cas
mais comment pourrait fonctionner cette
union plus
large les pays candidats doivent
effectuer des réformes en interne mais
pensez-vous qu'également que que l'Union
européenne doit également faire des
réformes et je me demande s'il y a un
débat en Ukraine
sur le type d'union que vous souhaitez
rejoindre merci beaucoup euh monsieur le
conseiller je vous laisse répondre en 2
minutes aux propos ou ou les commenter
hein donc vous avez eu notamment trois
tris voire quatre questions précises et
puis après on donne la parole au
sénateur oui alors je vous expliquerai
après parce qu'il faudra aller très
vite allez-y Monsieur Merci pour vos
questions je tâche de répondre autant
que je peux euh je commence par mes
remerciements parce que euh bon je sens
ce soutien il y a il y a des inquiétudes
toujours parce que c'est un processus
difficile euh mais je dirais que
l'Ukraine cette fois euh va prouver la
trè fois ses inspirations et c'est et et
ce que l'Ukraine est capable d'adhérer à
l'Union Européen la première fois
c'était quand
même il y a 10 ans pendant la
révoluation des dignité et euh le peuple
ukrainien a prouvé qu'elle peut qu'elle
peut changer qu'elle peut changer le
pays qu'il peut
changer le gouvernement changer tout en
fait on a tout
changé deuxème fois on a on a prouvé
qu'on est capable euh il y a un an
malheureusement après cette l'agression
de grande échelle avec l'agresseur qui
est puissante très forte
et bon c'est c'est c'est jamais jamais
imaginé euh même pas pas euh en Ukraine
mais en Russie même par les par les
peuple russe et troè fois cette fois
nous euh nous devons le prouver que nous
sommes
euh nous avons mérité cette cette
addhision et
euh cette fois euh
h je dirais que
les Ukrainiens euh ont consacré cette
euh ces ces 10 ans pour prouver bon j'ai
euh je peux je peux je peux pas dire que
euh euh aucun autre peuple européen n'a
n'a pas n'a pas démontré ça n'a pas
prouvé ça mais pour nous c'était un
processus quand même tragique et
difficile
euh
[Musique]
pour euh c'est euh si si je peux
répondre à la première question comme ça
parce que
euh c'est c'est quelque
chose existentiel pour l'Ukraine pas
seulement euh la lutte et la victoire
cette guerre mais l'adhésion à l'Union
Européen je parle de 10 ans mais euh
toute l'histoire de
l'Ukraine montre que l'Ukraine était
toujours la partie de
l'Europe pour pour le processus
d'adhésion euh et si si on parle des
difficultés au
niveau en répondant à votre question
concernant les les les difficultés au
niveau des relation bilatérales c'est
toujours la question des négociation on
peut on peut toujours négocier on peut
toujours parler il y a il y a certaines
périodes comme nous avons vu il y a
quelques mois
euh disons politisation des certains
problèmes qui sont disparus maintenant
c'est c'est disparu avec la Pologne
est-ce que vous vous voyez maintenant
tous ces propos assez assez fermes qu'on
a vu il y a il Liu de mois avec avant
les élections et avec le peuple polonais
avec la Pologne on est on est également
les les les pays frères et nous pouvons
nous sommes capables de négocier et
trouver un accord euh la même question
avec l'Hongrie
euh cette question a été même euh
mentionnée par la commission européen et
je dirais qu'on a déjà déjà euh fait
fait beaucoup donc euh pour euh pour
pour les recommandations de la
Commission de la Vénise de juin 2023 et
octobre 2023 nous avons déjà proposé euh
à nos à nos partenaires hongrois les
solutions
euh le 20 le 24 novembre il y a quelques
jours
seulement le gouvernement ukrainien
adopté et proposé au Parlement le projet
de la loi portant les modification des
certains lois Ukrainiens concernant l'
examen de l'évolution des experts de
cons du Conseil de l'Europe et ses
organs pour les droits d'une minorité
nationale euh ce projet de loi vise
précialement à renforcer la mise en
œuvre des droits et libertés des
personnes appartenants au minorité
nationale conformément aux
recommandations de la Commission de
Vénise il y a il y a euh euh dans cette
dans cette tâche euh trois questions qui
sont euh déjà
euh discuté avec les
angrois nous avons quelques quelques
questions à régler mais mon idée bon
l'idée de ma
réponse pour pour voir bon plus large
ces problèmes ce que nous nous sommes
nous sommes prêts à euh à trouver un
accord donc c'est c'est la question des
négociation euh toute tout le tout le
processus de de l'adhésion il y a il y a
demain technique il y a demain de
négociation
technique c'est le Parlement c'est notre
travail à domicile à accomplir mais ça
prend quelques temps mais on peut
compter mais les les questions des
négociation avec nos partenaires avec la
Pologne avec les pays
que que nous
sommes avec avec avec qui nous sommes
les partenaires c'est la voix de de des
accords c'est c'est c'est la voie de
négociations et c'est
faisable
pour
euh pour notre pour nos réflexions
concernant élargissement de l'Union
Européen euh c'est euh à notre avis euh
la question des membres des membres de
l'Union Européen nous euh nous proposons
euh aujourd'hui nous sommes dans dans un
rôle pas des demandeurs mais nous nous
proposons nous proposons non euh
euh
euh comment dire nos idées nos euh nos
propositions pour améliorer euh l'Union
et euh c'est euh c'est également une
partie de la question de euh de Madame
pour pour notre vision quelle euh quelle
union nous voyons quelleunion
euh nous euh nous cherchons à à
adhérer c'est vraiment les euh une bonne
question mais c'est un peu euh la
question romantique je dirais en Ukraine
c'est les valeurs que nous euh que nous
espérons à adhérer que nous nous nous
espérons à partager et
euh en en parlant si si vous venez en
Ukraine et vous posez cette question aux
Ukrainiens vous
euh vous recevez la même la même la même
réponse c'est c'est les
valeurs comme je dis notre peuple a
souffert déjà de cette l'influence
soviétique russe et nous ne voulons plus
d'êtreampon entre la Russie et l'Europe
et nous proposons nous proposons quelque
chose à à l'Union
Européen pour
euh minut encore minute euh je dis j'ai
euh alors pour Monsieur martiac euh je
je je partage votre opinion que parmi
des de l'État membres euh des
inquiétudes qui sont plus en plus euh
dominant et
euh il euh la question est toujours
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que l'Ukraine
peut apporter à l'Union Européen bon
c'est une bonne question c'est une euh
mais euh je dis toujours que l'Union
l'Ukraine apporte à l'Union Européen la
dynamique qui est perdu à mon avis euh
corrigez-moi si si je me trompe mais
l'Ukraine peut apporter cette dynamique
à l'Union Européen pas seulement pour
l'élargissement mais pour les processus
intérieur
euh c'est et c'est toujours des
nouvelles opportunités économiques en
plus
euh parmi les premiers secteurs qui qui
figurent c'est la construction euh la
banque la finances les industries et
autres technologies donc nous euh nous
nous avons quelque chose à
proposer merci merci Monsieur le
Conseiller on va passer donner la parole
à nos sénateurs euh alors si vous n'avez
jamais eu la chance de participer à la
coszak je vais vous en donner le régime
c'est une minute la prise de parole donc
je vous laisse prendre la parole chacun
pour une minute en commençant par Nadia
sologou qui a demandé la parole
présidente du groupe d'amitié France
Ukraine merci monsieur le Président
alors en une minute très symboliquement
j'ai pu accompagner Marc fenau à un
déplacement en Ukraine il rencontrait le
le ministre de l'Agriculture ukrainien
le 9 novembre voilà et je pense que la
question l'agriculture est au centre de
des inquiétudes et et des débats et
cristallise même certaines inquiétudes
de nos propres agriculteurs français
donc juste un mot pour dire que la la
position du ministre a été constante je
en tout cas je me permets de la relayer
je peux pas parler pour lui mais ce que
j'en ai compris c'est qu'il y avait un
long travail de pour aligner les normes
et qu' il y avait un long processus à
mettre en place et puis il fallait aussi
un long travail pour rassurer nos
producteurs de manière à ce que à terme
l'agriculture ukrainienne est soit
considérée comme un atout de plus dans
la main de l'Europe pour aller chercher
de nouveaux marchés en Asie ou
ou en Afrique et non pas un déferlement
de produits concurrents à l'intérieur de
l'Europe donc il y a un long travail
pour avoir cette vision là et puis
aligner les les quantités parce
qu'évidemment les volumes font très peur
à nos
producteurs nationaux
voilà merci oui bien sûr c'est c'est
c'est un des sujets qui revient très
très régulièrement alors je vais donner
la parole à Martha Sidra et Didier Marie
qui sont nos rapporteurs sur
l'élargissement une minute et ou merci
Président je ne vais pas soulever les
questions des Balcans cela a été très
bien posé par Monsieur martiac et
Monsieur
Marek moi je voudrais revenir j'ai deux
questions très précise la première la
question vous a été posée par Madame
poliie sur les attendu de leucrain
vis-à-vis de cette adhésion future vous
avez évoqué une question un peu
romantique une réponse un peu romantique
de la part du peuple ukrainien moi je
souhaitais vous poser la même question
mais aussi d'un point de vue avancé sur
l'état de droit et sur la corruption qui
est un vrai problème en Ukraine donc je
voudrais que vous nous disiez quels sont
les progrès éventuels que vous faites
dans la matière et les réformes que vous
menez et ma deuxème question Monsieur le
Conseiller concerne le Kosovo puisque
vous faites partie de ces états qui
n'ont pas reconnu le Kosovo et
l'indépendance du Kosovo or lorsque le
Kosovo a posé sa candidature vous vous
étiez abstenu d'ailleurs cela a créé une
forme de tension avec la Serbie donc je
voulais connaître la position précise de
l'Ukraine vis-à-vis de votre
positionnement aujourd'hui de ce qui se
passe dans les Balcans occidentaux et
notamment ce conflit larvé qui existe
aujourd'hui toujours entre le Kosovo et
la Serbie et qui est un vrai sujet par
rapport à l'élargissement de cette zone
merci
Didier
merci Monsieur le Conseiller
euh l'élargissement à pour les Européens
trois objectifs leur sécurité et donc la
vôtre en même temps
euh l'affirmation de notre puissance
économique et et numérique et euh la
nécessité d'une convergence économique
et sociale ma question portera sur euh
la situation
économique du pays euh l'Ukraine est en
guerre elle subit des bombardements
permanents est-ce que votre économie
aujourd'hui est résiliente est-elle
capable de
répondre aux objectifs
d'intégration au marché unique queles
sont les mesures que vous souhaitez
prendre dans le domaine deuxè question
euh est liée au au processus euh de
participation de la population euh on on
voit euh en Europe aujourd'hui euh une
légère diminution de l'intérêt de
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine du fait de la
lcitude de la guerre est-ce que ce
phénomène existe aussi en Ukraine et
quelle est la place de la société civile
dans le processus d'adhésion on entend
beaucoup le gouvernement des
parlementaires mais qu'en est-il de la
société civile et qu'en est-il
réellement de la population aujourd'hui
André richchard donc pour le Partenariat
oriental nous avons deux représentants
Andr Richard et Gisel Jourda
oui Giselle va vous parler certainement
beaucoup plus clairement que moi de du
Partenariat oriental c'est c'est son
c'est son moi je voudrais revenir sur la
question que vous avez posé Mara de
Sidrac monsieur le Premier conseiller
vous êtes un pays en guerre euh vous
nous dites vous avez été très court
là-dessus vous dites avoir fait beaucoup
de progrès sur l'état de droit
respectivement la lutte contre la la
corruption est-ce que dans un lapse de
temps aussi court s'agissant d'un pays
en guerre il a été possible d'aller
aussi loin que vous le souhaitiez compte
tenu notamment du poids qu'a dû prendre
l'armée et que prend encore l'armée à
l'heure actuelle à cet égard je vous
remercie Giselle
oui merci monsieur le Président
oui moi effectivement je souhaiterais
donc évoquer comme la dit mon collègue
monsieur rchat le Partenariat oriental
parce que lorsqu'on rentre dans la
perspective de la voie de
l'élargissement je crois qu'à un certain
moment donné il faut quantifier ce qui
s'est passé depuis 2017 où le
Partenariat oriental est devenu effectif
et où cet accord d'association avec l'UE
mettez poser un cadre que ce soit dans
le domaine don des des des libertés de
la transparence de la justice donc et du
libre change ça aller au-delà des
aspects donc commerciaux donc je
souhaiterais savoir donc comment donc
quelle année aujourd'hui le bilan et
comment vous envisagez cette passerelle
donc de passer de la dimension du
Partenariat oriental à la dimension de
des
des critères demandés par par
l'élargissement qui ne sont pas tout à
fait les
mêmes collègue Vogel qui va s'exprimer
aussi et Claude kierne pour terminer euh
oui ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
dulani
euh concerne la politique française il y
a la politique française par rapport à
l'Ukraine c'est qui est une chose et
puis il y a nécessairement en négatif la
politique française par rapport à la
Russie et en principe la la première
n'allant pas sans l'autre il faut qu'il
y a une cohérence entre les deux donc il
a fait une allusion à la politique
française à l'égard de la Russie en
disant que elle devrait être plus claire
est-ce qu'il pourrait développer un peu
c'est pas le temps de de dire
grand-chose he voilà
ça merci Claude pour terminer oui merci
président merci pour ces propos
introductifs euh beaucoup de points ont
été abordés puisque euh des réformes
législatives vous l'avez dit ont été
lancées prévu euh dans votre pays malgré
la guerre et donc moi je j'aimerais
savoir quel est l'impact de la guerre et
ses conséquences sur ce programme de
réforme qui sont essentiels à la
trajectoire européenne de de votre pays
et puis une autre question puisque nous
avons aborder ici dans cette commission
l'enlèvement massif d'enfants euh où en
êtes-vous des dossiers des plaintes des
éventuels retours et et rapatriment bon
vous avez eu beaucoup de questions
monsieur le conseiller je sais pas si on
pourra en en 3 minutes qui nous reste
répondre à tout euh ça vaudra peut-être
le coup d'une autre audition bien sûr
mais en tout cas il y a il y a quelques
questions redondantes et intéressantes
sur lesquelles vous pouvez répondre et
Monsieur Juliani qui devra répondre à
Monsieur Vogel
aussi merci merci Madam les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs j'essaie à à
répondre t les
questions d'abord tout ce qui concerne
la corruption et c'était évoqué par la
par les décision de de la commission
européen et comme vous le sa a
euh notre Parlement travaille travaille
et euh comme je dis ces dernières
semaines le progrès est significatif
d'abord
pour pour être assez contrcet donc le
gouvernement devait augmenter le nombre
desésemployés du bureau national
antiorruption c'était fait le 1er
novembre le projet de la loi euh pourant
modification de la loi concernant le
bureau national de la lutte contre la
corruption
ét adopté comme la base pour une
réduction du délai de préparation la 2e
lecture le projet augmente le nombre
maximum de cette Agen de ce bureau des
700 à 1000 personnes y compris le
personnel de
direction 2è structure pour pour la
lutte contre la corruption c'est euh
l'agence de la prévention de de la
corruption le le même jour le 21
novembre le projet de la loi était
adopté
et c'est tout euh en conirité des
dispositions avec les conclusions de l'
de la commission européen euh le projet
de la loi prévoit la suppression des
restrictions au pouvoir de l'agence pour
poursuivre l'inspection des biens ayant
déjà passé avec succès l'inspection et
pour vérifier la légalité des biens
acquis pour pour les sujets de la euh
déclaration avant la nomination des
fonctions publiques
euh pour euh la la troisème tâche qui a
été avvoquée par la commission EUR
européen également c'était euh euh le
plan d'action
anti oligarchique euh et et
euh la
Rada donc le projet a adopté le projet
ukrainien pour le lobbying et le
plusudoyer des bon fois en Ukraine
l'objectif du projet de loi est de
garantir la base juridique du lobbying
en Ukraine conformément aux pratiques et
normes
internationales de réglementer
interaction des fonctionnaires des
autorités de l'État et des organs
d'autonomie local avec les personnes
intéressées sujet de lobbing donc c'est
euh tous ces actions de la Rada prouvent
que on essaie de compter et et prendre
en compte tous les exigences on on fait
tout possible pour pour qu'on pour qu'on
oublie la corruption comme euh déjà la
notion en Ukraine c'est pas facile euh
c'est c'est devenu quelque chose déjà
euh
absolument négatif en Ukraine et c'est
également la question de du rôle de de
la société civile dans tous ces
processus et c'est c'est
vraiment le rôle crucial de la société
civile pour tous ces processus euh si
vous euh si vous voulez vous pouvez
consulter les les amendements les
propositions
euh prise en compte par la Rada
et je dirais 90 10 % des tous ces
propositions vient de la société civile
ça euh ça prouve que euh c'est c'est
vraiment le peuple qui qui exige tout
tous ce changement qui est absolument
épuisé des
euh de de la corruption
euh des de tous ces euh de tout ce qu'on
maintenant on on plus euh
euh on parle plus de de la corruption
comme un problème mais euh on oublie
toujours euh euh des euh le le le
progrès de la lutte contre ces ces
effets
euh sur
euh
euh sur Kosovo euh alors euh il y a il y
a au au cours de ces euh 2 années il y a
il y a beaucoup de négociations bon il y
a beaucoup de réflexions comment dire
parce que euh il y a des parallèles
entre Kosovo et et la Crimée et euh euh
les euh le ministère desaires étrangères
et le Parlement la commission des
affaires étrangères on ont fait déjà des
déclarations parce que euh c'est euh
c'est la question qui qui qui change et
euh la euh la commission euh la la
position sur le Kosovo sera changé sera
changé de la quelle manière et de quelle
euh euh de quelle direction je peux je
peux pas dire euh parce que euh pour le
par exemple le le ministère ça reste
assez ferme mais euh les négociations
les les réflexions et discussions dans
le Parlement nous nous oblige d'être euh
toujours assez
prudent
pour
les pour les question de de l'économie
ukrainienne actuelle c'est c'est une
question très très difficile on souffre
on a on a perdu une tiers de
notre économie de de notre
industrie maintenant c'est c'est
vraiment avec l'aide de nos partenaire
que nous pouvons survivre euh mais quand
même euh notre économie montre
euh montre les dynamiques positives euh
assez assez limité pour l'instant
mais avec les conditions
euh des bombardements des bon de la
guerre en général
c'est la question que
euh la solution c'est que
pour c'est avec le soutien de nos
partenaires que N nous pouvons survivre
maintenant mais euh la le potentiel de
notre économie même avec tout ce qu'on a
perdu énorme euh ce que j'ai
euh euh pour pour le Partenariat
oriental euh je crois que il ne s'agit
pas de de changement on on reste
toujours et pour nous c'est un
instrument euh on est déjà euh un très
bon expérience euh y compris euh le le
Partenariat oriental et y compris euh
euh l'accord d'association je peux je
peux dire que c'est les deux les deux
instruments que nous pouvons
euh utiliser et nous pouvons euh
démontrer que avec les deux euh euh
l'accord d'association et le Partenariat
oriental nous pouvons prouver que nous
euh nous avons nous avons un potentiel
et on n'oublie pas pour l'instant pour
euh
euh au minimum avant l'adhésion euh les
deux instruments donc on on continueer à
travailler
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
conseiller pour cet exercice donc je
sais qu'il n'était pas aisé pour vous
mais euh voilà on a réussi quasiment à
tenir euh à tenir le temp mais c'était
c'était très très intéressant et merci
aux collègues de s'être aussi
conformé à la priorité mais je laisse
aussi monsieur Juliani
présent répondre à Monsieur Vogel merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
sénateur de votre question on pourrait
demander à Madame Van retgem qui est un
auteur à succès sur avec son livre sur
nstream ce qu'elle pense de la politique
française à égarde la Russie ou bien à
Madame Sylvie Koffman qui vient de
rédiger un livre très bien sur les
aveuglés et montrant combien d'ailleurs
je ne m'explique pas comme observateur
comment la politique française peut être
si favorable à la Russie je ne vois
aucun intérêt ni historique ni un
intérêt national qui nous permettent de
ne pas être ferme à l'égard de ces
agression révisionniste impérialiste de
la Russie à laquelle il faut vraiment
s'opposer et mettre fin et un dernier
ouvrage que je recommanderais à ceux qui
ne l'ont pas lu c'est celui de
l'ambassadeur Gérard AR qui raconte il
se branch sur la diplomatie de l'Europe
et de la France entre les deux guerres
et qui explique que Maréchal Foch
recommande à clémenau d'aller à Berlin
pour faire défiler les troupes pour
montrer aux Allemands qu'ils ont perdu
la guerre et
clémenau qui était désireux de mettre
fin à à ce conflit épouvantable dit
écoutez non faisons le traité de
Versailles et cetera et que le fait que
les Allemands n'ai pas compris le peuple
nit pas compris qu'il avait perdu la
guerre a permis euh toute cette
rétorique sur le coup de poignard dans
le dos qui a permis à Hitler de revenir
au pouvoir et qui a déclairé déclarer et
permis fonder la Seconde Guerre mondiale
je pense que si nous n'arrêtons pas la
Russie aujourd'hu auourd'hui et je
mesure mes propos monsieur le Président
si nous ne l'arrêtons pas si nous ne
sommes pas déterminés nous aurons à
faire la guerre contre elle un jour
parce qu'elle continuera ce son œuvre de
déstabilisation je mesure la gravité de
mes propos mais depuis Aristote on sait
que on fait aussi la guerre pour gagner
la
paix merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
tous euh donc voilà maintenant on va
recevoir l'ambassadrice de Moldavie qui
doit être arrivé je pense et j'
raccompagne monsieur le
premier
bien tout le monde a repris sa place
merci Madame l'ambassadrice bienvenue au
Sénat dont vous êtes à présent très
familière et je suis très heureux de de
vous retrouver les contacts les visites
entre nos deux pays sont sont fréquents
et la diplomatie parlementaire est
active vous accompagnez régulièrement le
vice-promier ministre niku popeskou au
Sénat ce qui nous permet d'échanger avec
lui pour suivre les progrès de votre
pays sur la voie de la candidature de
l'Union européenne nous avons le plaisir
de vous recevoir aujourd'hui pour faire
un point sur l'état de la préparation de
votre pays à quelques semaines du
Conseil européen de mi-décembre qui sera
décisif et après les recommandations
encourageantes de la Commission
européenne publié le 8 novembre dans le
cadre du paquet élargissement qui
préconise l'ouverture des négociations
vous connaissez le soutien constant du
Sénat à votre pays à sa démarche
européenne encore tout récemment
manifesté à kishinao avec par le
président de notre le vice-président de
notre commission André richichard qui
est ici présent dans le cadre de la
réunion des présidents de commission des
affaires européennes et des Affaires
étrangères des 27 organisé pour
constituer une plateforme parlementaire
de soutien à à la Moldavie nous
entendons insister auprès de nos nos
partenaires européens pardon sur le lien
entre l'élargissement et les réformes
nécessaires de l'Union européenne afin
qu'élargie l'Union européenne se trouve
renforcée et non affaiblie mais pour
l'heure nous souhaitons vous entendre
sur l'avancement de votre pays désormais
candidat officiel à l'adhésion la
Commission européenne soulligne dans son
rapport les progrès importants réalisés
par la Moldavie qui fait l'objet de
menace hybride mais a entrepris une
vaste réforme de la justice et de ses
organ de lutte contre la corruption et
s'emploie à renforcer la protection des
droits de l'homme des mesures telles que
la confiscation de biens liés à la
criminalité organisée ont été mis en
place sur le plan économique aussi votre
pays avance jusqu'à l'an dernier la
Russie était son unique fournisseur de
gaz la Moldavie a réussi à réduire cette
dépendance grâce à une politique
déterminée de diversification avec
l'aide financière de l'Union européenne
le raccordement avec le gestionnaire de
réseau européen a eu lieu dès mars 2022
en même même temps que pour l'Ukraine la
solidarité européenne concrète est aussi
traduite cette année par votre
participation à la plateforme commune
d'achat de gaz mise en place par l'Union
européenne c'est un acquis commun de
l'Union européenne de la communauté
politique européenne dont vous avez
d'ailleurs accueilli avec succès et je
vous avais vu quelques jours avant très
stressé la réunion au sommet le premer
juin il est certain qu'un effort
financier important est requis pour
intégrer la Moldavie au marché intérieur
européen c'est en ce sens que la
plateforme de soutien à la Moldavie
coprésidée par la France la Roumanie et
l'Allemagne mobilise les institutions
financière internationale nous soutenons
ces démarches principal partenairire
commercial et investisseurs en Moldavie
l'Union européenne continue
d'accompagner votre pays dans le
prolongement des acquis du Partenariat
oriental et des mesures de
libéralisation temporaire des échanges
prises l'an dernier et prorogé jusqu'à
l'an prochain je souhaite que la France
y prenne toute sa part comme elle l'a
fait pour la réduction des frais
d'itinérance obtenu par accord entre les
principaux opérateurs j'étais intervenu
à ce sujet au près du commissaire
Thierry Breton et je me réjouis de ce
geste concret d'intégration européenne
madame l'ambassadrice nous vous écoutons
pendant 5 minutes notre format est
contraint mais quelquefois la contrainte
c'est aussi le pragmatisme puis je
donnerai la parole aux experts pour 2
minutes comme ils l'ont fait auparavant
puis au rapporteurs et aux collègues
sénateurs pour des questions
suffisamment brèves pour nous permettre
d'entendre vos réponses dans le temps
imparti madame l'ambassadrice c'est à
vous pour 5 minutes une forme de grand
oral
voilà monsieur le
Président chers sénateur je vous
remercie pour cette invitation et pour
l'attention accordée à la République de
Moldova et à son parcours
européen l'événement d'aujourd'hui est
pour nous tout d'abord une bonne
occasion de vous présenter les dernières
évolutions mais également de faire un
échange de vue sur l'intégration
européen de la Moldavie et sur le
processus de l'arrégissement de l'Union
Européen comme vous le savez le 8
novembre dernier la Commission
européenne a recommandé l'ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion avec la
République de Moldova et pour nous c'est
un signe fort de soutien de notre
objectif européenne mais aussi en
reconnaissance des progrès soustenables
réalisé par les autorités depuis
l'obtention du statut de pays candidat
en juin 2022 mais aussi depuis que le
nouveau gouvernement a mise en œuvre une
autre vitesse sur la mise en œuvre
de toutes les provisions de l'accord
d'association je je je fais référence à
la mise en œuvre des recommandations de
l'Union européenne la poursuite des
réformes qui ont contribué au
développement de l'état du droit mais
aussi au renforcement des capacités
administratives à une politique ère
active et équilibré avec un haut degré
d'alignement sur les message de l'Union
européenne et d'autres partenaires ce
sont des réformes qui conduisent à une
démocratisation durable de notre pays et
qui constituent également un engagement
fort de notre pays à défendre et
promouvoir les valeurs démocratiques et
européens bien évidemment nous attendons
avec beaucoup d'impatience la décision
du Conseil européen du du 14- 155
décembre concernant le lancement des
négociations avec les pays candidats en
étant très conscient de la
responsabilité et du parcours qui ni
facile ni court c'est pour ça que nous
sommes très déterminés à continuer à
travailler sans relâche pour la mise en
œuvre de nos recommandations de la
Commission européenne dont la plupart
ont été déjà réalisé en intégralité mais
nous avons aussi déjà mise en œuvre
plusieurs réformes en réalisant des
progrès significativs et durables et
espérons on que ces progrès serviront de
base solide et crédibl pour que le
Conseil européen décide le lancement des
négociations d'adhésion en décembre euh
prochain nous sommes très reconnaissants
à la France et à toutes les partenaires
européennes pour cette confiance et cet
appui parce que c'est bien d'être seul
très déterminant mais c'est plus
important d'avoir les partenaires et des
amis à côté et nous souhaitons que
l'Europe soit unie forte et en paix et
nous croyons que le processus
d'élargissement le permettra nous
voulons contribuer à une Europe unie et
à une sécurité commune et c'est dans ce
sens que il est très important d'entamer
les négociations d'adhésion le plus
possible même s'ils dureront plusieurs
années nous voulons et aussi nous
pouvons contribuer au projet européen
parce que je crois que d'habitude
c'était l'image de la République de
Moldova par des crises des situations
très troublant mais de même façon la
République de moldava ne peut pas être
seulement un bénéficiaire mais aussi un
contribuable à tout ce que ça signifie
l'Union Européen et la grand famille
européen et dans ce perspective l'année
dernière la président Maya sandou et la
République de Moldova ont soutinue sans
équivoque l'initiative du président
Emmanuel Macron relative à la création
de la communauté politique européen et
comme t vous le savez le 1er juin
dernier nous étions privilégiés de re
les hutees du 2e sommet de la communauté
politique européen organisé à seulement
20 km de la frontière avec l'Ukraine où
ce sont réunis 49 dirigeants européens
qui ont discuté des actions et des
efforts conjoints pour faire face à des
défis communs tels que la guerre contre
l'Ukraine des questions de sécurité plus
large la résilience énergétique et les
interconnexions en Europe pour un
continent mieux connecté et plus stable
et comme vous avez mentionné monsieur le
Président pour nous c'était très
important d'avoir aussi un résultat plus
concret pour la population qui s'était
matérialisé par l'accord sur les frais
d'itinérance et on espère et on est sûr
qu'à partir de 1ier janvier
2024 toutes les nouveaux tarifs seront
en vigueur pour les Moldaves mais aussi
pour les Moldaves qui se trouvent à
l'étrangère en tant qu'ambassadrice en
France je ne pouveait
pas ne pas éviter ou ne pas aborder le
soutien de la France dans le processus
de la mise en œuvre des réformes et de
rapprochement de standard de l'Union
Européen avec le support français nous
avons entamé des partenariats importants
dans tous les domaines grâce au dialogue
politique dynamique établi ces dernières
années entre nous deux président la
France nous accompagne dans la réforme
de la justice et la lutte contre la
corruption et inclu en détachant un
expert de l'expertise France auprès de
l'administration présidentielle en
Moldavie la FD déploie avec succès ces
projets dans notre pays depuis euh 2022
nous sommes également très
recéonnaissant pour le soutien et la
solidarité française afin de surmonter
les conséquences de l'invasion armée de
l'Ukraine par la Russie et pour gérer
les flux de réfugiés à travers la
plateforme de soutien à la Moldavie avec
l'appui direct de la France qui s'assume
la crprésidence à côté de l'allemand et
la Roumanie comme vous le savez la 4e
édition de ce forum a eu lieu à kishenau
le 17 octobre euh cette année et aussi
dans cette perspective parce que vous
avez mentionné du l'énergie euh le
groupe de travail sur l'indépendance
énergétique dans le cadre du de la
plateforme et co-présidé par la France
et l'Italie et euh grâce au ces efforts
on a réussi d'aider la population
moldave avec le support financière
pendant l'hiver passé mais de même façon
d'entamer les nouveaux politiques avec
la participation des et avec
l'implication de l'expertise française
euh pour assurer une autre approche mais
plutôt l'indépendance énergétique de
Moldavie dans ce sens les dernières 2
années l'agenda interne de la Moldavie
est devenue une continuation de notre
programme avec l'Union européenne et ce
que nous faisons comme politique interre
repose sur nos relations avec l'Union
Européen pour nous c'est très important
que l'Union Européen et les États
membres on déployer des efforts
extraordinaires pour nous apporter de
l'assistance dans toutes les domaines
clés échanges commerciaux économique
énergie transport soutien financière
notre coopération dans le domaine
militaire et sécuritaire c'est beaucoup
renforcée l'Union européenne a récemment
ouvert une mission civile de conseil en
République de Moldavie pour renforcer la
résilience du secteur de la sécurité par
la mission de partenariat de l'Union
Européen de même
euh cette année le Pays-Bas et la
Belgique ont annoncé l'ouverture des
ambassades à kisheno le Luxembourg a
accrédité le premier ambassadeur non
résident pour la Moldavie la Grèce et
l'Espagne ont annoncé leur intention
d'ouvrir les ambassades à kishinao
jusqu'à la fin de l'année et encore une
fois c'est un preuve pour nous de
support et d'intérêt pour notre
pays bien sûr que euh il est absolument
nécessaire d'avoir des résultats
concrets je reviens toujours sur le fait
que on demande l'adhésion à l'Union
Européen mais on demande aussi le
support pour la mise en œuvre de toutes
les transformations parce que on veut
être un partenaire crédible euh et fort
dans la famille
européenne merci beaucoup madame
l'ambassadrice euh donc je vais passer
la parole à nos experts sur le même
régime que que tout à l'heure donc
monsieur
Juliani merci monsieur le Président
Madame comme l'ambassadrice euh s'il est
un pays euh où euh qui compte beaucoup
d'amis chez nous en France et bien la
Moldavie n'est-ce pas vous le savez avec
d'ailleurs une forte orientation
francophone à laquelle nous sommes
toujours très très sensibles euh je
voudrais dire que je suis
particulièrement impressionné par la
manière dont ce pays se transforme euh
en se rapprochant de l'Union européenne
je pense que si il y a un une qualité à
le processus d'adhésion c'est bien les
conséquences sur la transformation
interne des pays qui veulent rejoindre
l'Union et que c'est particulièrement
spectaculaire en Moldavie c'est pour ça
qu'il nous faut le soutenir si vous me
permettez monsieur le Président de
prendre cet exemple de la plateforme
d'aide à la Moldavie que nous avons mis
en œuvre je je pense que vous pourriez
votre commission pourrait peut-être en
tirer une étude une réflexion
supplémentaire ne sera-il pas nécessaire
aussi dans le processus d'adhésion et
compris pour l'Ukraine ou pour d'autres
dans les Balcans que les États-membres
qui sont d'abord ceux qui vont permettre
l'intégration des nouveaux États
reprennent un peu la main sur le
processus technocratique qui est conduit
par la commission il faut bien sûr
respecter les critères mais je crois que
par exemple la nomination d'un monsieur
élargissement comme on avait eu pour
Monsieur brexit serait peut-être
l'occasion de reprendre la dimension
géopolitique qui marquerait peut-être et
permettrait de dialoguer aussi avec les
opinions publiques et avec les états
candidats au niveau qu'il convient
plutôt que de dérouler euh simplement
des conditions que d'ailleurs euh
monsieur popescou est venu nous
expliquer que vous aviez rempli à peu
près toutes
Aujourd'hui merci Monsieur Juliani on se
faisait une réflexion vous avez parlé de
Monsieur brexit en parlant de Monsieur
Barnier d'accord donc il était
commissaire et là il y a un commissaire
à
l'élargissement mais c'est la commission
c'est ce que vous voulez dire rendit
compte au conseil il rendit compte au
Conseil d'accord
ok euh monsieur
Chopin merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup madame l'ambassadrice je crois
que le temps est très contraint je me
bornerai peut-être à deux
questions si si vous en êtes d'accord la
la première en fait porte
sur les réflexions actuelles en fait de
de réforme du processus d'adhésion on
parle beaucoup d'adhésion graduelle
d'adhésion progressive et notamment avec
une possible inversion des logiques
politiques et institutionnelles d'un
côté et de la logique d'intégration
économique de de
l'autre comment votre pays accueille ces
ces réflexions et l'éventuelle évolution
de du processus d'adhésion en vue de de
ces formes d'adhésion graduelle et et
progressive deème question toujours sur
le processus d'adhésion mais mais sous
un autre angle processus d'adhésion
c'est un processus qui est technique
mais qui est aussi politique qui est
politique du point de vue des des
étatsmembres des des gouvernements
nationaux mais aussi du point de vue de
de l'opinion publique j'ai déjà insisté
dans l'audition précédente en fait sur
sur ce point mais quand on regarde les
chiffres des enquêtes d'opinion récentes
mai- juin 2023 les Eurobaromètres le
soutien en moyenne des européens
interrogés à l'élargissement à un
certain nombre de nouveaux pays membres
dont dont le vôtre en fait s'élève à 53
% donc c'est majoritaire quand on
regarde par contre en France ce taux euh
il est de 35 % euh donc il est
considérablement beaucoup plus bas et
donc la la question qui se pose c'est
évidemment la question du du discours en
fait politique la question des arguments
en faveur en fait de de l'adhésion de de
nouveau pays notamment le le vôtre et la
question de l'appropriation démocratique
en fait de cette future échelle de
l'union de l'Union é
lge merci Monsieur Chopin Monsieur
matchek Merci monsieur monsieur le
Président merci Madame l'ambassadris euh
je vais aussi passer directement aux
questions et j'en ai également deux
alors je rebondis sur la question de
l'opinion publique mais cette fois-ci du
côté de de votre pays euh c'est-à-dire
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
votre point de vue sur l'état de de
consensus national autour de de la
question européenne en
Moldavie consensus à l'échelle aussi de
la scène politique et dans la mesure où
ce consensus n'est peut-être pas parf
fait quelles sont ces initiatives est-ce
que la majorité actuelle est en mesure
de de faire un pas et comment elle peut
entraîner je dirais une partie au moins
de l'opposition dans cette dynamique
parce qu'il me semble toujours très
problématique pour l'Union européenne
d'envisager l'adhésion d'un pays oou une
alternance politique éventuelle pourrait
remettre en cause je dirais le l'ancrage
fondamental d'un pays dans dans sa
direction européenne si je puis dire et
deuxième question qui qui est d'ailleur
très
voisine il me semble que que même les
dirigeants actuels en tout cas encore en
printemps peut-être que les choses ont
évolué
depuis affirmai une volonté d'adhésion à
l'Union européenne pas une adhésion à
l'OTAN et ils affirmaient une volonté de
rester un pays neutre personnellement je
suis très sceptique sur la capacité de
l'Union européenne à faire adhérer des
pays disons qui sont pas très loin de la
Russie disons comme ça en terme
géographique sans la garantie de
sécurité de l'OTAN en tout cas en l'état
actu actu des choses et dans un avenir
prévisible est-ce que pour vous c'est
tenable cette idée d'ailleurs qu' on
voit que même certains pays très
attachés à la neutralité dans l'Union
européenne il y en a quand même deux sur
quat qui ont renoncé à cette neutralité
récemment et pas pas les moindres en la
matière d'attachement à la
neutralité est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est tenable cette cette volonté
d'adhérer à l'Union européenne et pas à
l'OTAN et là encore derrière question de
l'opinion publique parce que j'ai cru
comprendre que l'opinion publique
effectivement est assez attaché à l'idée
de ne pas demander l'adhésion à l'OTAN
en tout a une bonne partie de l'opinion
publique comment vous envisagez ces
questions là merci beaucoup merci
Monsieur Marti madame bonjour euh trois
trois petites questions assez
spécifiques sur sur votre pays la
première sur l'immigration donc qui a
touché de façon massive la Moldavie je
crois que c'est c'est c'est un quart de
la population au moins eu est-ce que le
nouveau souffle maintenant européen et
et les perspectives d'adhésion qui qui
ont été offertes à la Moldavie se sont
traduites par à des retours des des
forces se viv au pays est-ce que comment
est-ce que cela est vécu euh est-ce que
vous pourvez nous donner quelques
indications en ce sens-là la deuxième
c'est c'est c'est un mot qui n'a pas
encore été prononcé c'est la
Transnistrie euh comment est-ce que vous
approchez ce problèmel euh parce qu'on
peut parler de réforme on peut parler de
de de de de préparer la
Moldavie mais le problème de la
Transnistrie est ce qu'il est c'est
l'obstacle majeur en tant que tel à
l'adhésion
effective on pense un petit peu à à la
Chypre mais mais au-delà de ça
simplement dans les Balcans on comprend
bien que toutes les les questions de
souveraineté contestées irrit et et et
et dévoie finalement assez facilement
les processus d'adhésion donc comment
quelle stratégie avez-vous pour coupler
un petit peu ces deux logiques ces deux
problématique celle de l'adhésion et de
la résolution de ce problème et la
troisième c'est c'est la solidarité dans
dans la façon de de de de peser sur sur
votre
candidature vous aviez un un un format
donc le le le trio d'associés avec
l'Ukraine et la Géorgie qui qui qui
s'est efforcé avec un certain succès à à
dissocier un petit peu du du Partenariat
oriental pour mettre sur la table les
perspectives d'adhésion est-ce que à
quoi vous êtes parvenu aujourd'hui ce ce
ce format donc de solidarité entre avec
d'autres pays Contin continuent-il
d'exister pour l'instant on comprend
bien que la Moldavie se se devient
devient assez proche et reste assez
proche l'Ukraine dans la façon de
présenter ses ces son son processus
pensez-vous à vous disjoindre à de
l'Ukraine donc reste de faire route seul
ou cherchez chercherez-vous à un certain
moment stratégiquement des des alliés
pour peser sur les débats dans dans au
sein de l'Union européenne et dans les
capitales merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et merci beaucoup madame la
l'ambassadrice j'ai la même question que
Florent sur votre lien avec l'Ukraine
dans ce
processus euh de adhésion euh et je
voulais savoir également ce que vous
pensez de cette communauté pour
réfléchir à vos défis communs mais
pensez-vous qu'il s'agisse plutôt d'une
salle d'attente pour l'élargissement
mais ou plutôt pensez-vous que cette
communauté pourrait aider en fait dans
ce chemin de l'intégration et de
l'adhésion de
l'élargissement globalement à toutes ces
questions vous préférez qu'on prenne
celle des sénateurs euh maintenant je
vous laisse répondre aux
experts 5 6 minutes oui d'accord euh je
reviens sur la francophonie c'est vrai
que la Moldavie tout d'abord c'est un
pays francophone et je crois que c'est
très important de réitérer le fait que
la République de Moldavie c'était
l'unique pays pendant l'Union soviétique
qui a eu langue d'origine latine mais
utiliser un alphabet chelque et quand on
a revenu à on a obtenu l'indépendance
dan on est revenu sur l'alphabet latine
et c'est seulement cette année que la
majorité politique s'est assumé la
responsabilité politique
euh de réviser et d'adopter toutes les
modifications législatives en vue
d'avoir partout dans la Constitution
dans toute la législation la langue
roumain et la langue russe reste comme
langue de communication interethnique
tenant compte de de l'existence de
plusieurs minorités et plusieurs ethnies
en mold
et encore une fois ici je crois que
c'est très important de réitérer que la
Moldavie a réussi de construire un
modèle très pacifique un modèle
constructive de vivre ensemble avec
plusieurs minorités avec plusieurs
ethnies et euh c'est aussi grâce à ce
modèle que les réfugiés ourainiens
l'année passée et aujourd'hui parce que
jusqu'à maintenant ça reste en Moldavie
officiellement 80000 réfugiés Ukrainiens
qui représente 3 % de notre population
qui qui vivent et qui sont acceptés dans
un esprit très responsable euh sur
l'adhésion
progressive et sur l'idée généralement
de l'élargissement tout d'abord je crois
que c'est très important et pour nous
c'était très encourageant d'avoir les
discussions et aussi le rapport des
sages demandé par les ministres pour
l'Europe de l'allemand et de la France
sur l'élargissement
c'est très important et très
encourageant car le Berlin et le Paris
entam les discussions sur
l'élargissement parce que finalement si
dans ces deux capitales existe un tel
débat c'est déjà très encourageant pour
la Moldavie et comme je disais avant
pour nous c'est clair que
euh Moldavie ne peut pas exister seule
et elle a besoin d'un partenariat et ce
partenariat reste toujours dans l'Union
européenne
et
euh l'objectif de transformer le pays et
d'être membre de l'Union européenne ça a
été pris depuis plusieurs années et
aucun parti politique ne peut pas
toucher à cet objective d'adhésion à
l'Union Européen parce que l'adhésion
finalement pour nous ça a commencé aussi
avec l'accord de de l'association avec
le régime libéralisé de visa depuis 2014
avec l'accord compréhensive de libre éch
change euh parce que et aujourd'hui par
exemple on a on a changé la géographie
des exports c'est pas seulement en vers
du l'est mais c'est c'est en vers du
ouest de même façon dans l'accord
compréhensive de libre échange on a mis
des conditionnalités aussi pour les
agents économiques du région
transnistrienne et aujourd'hui 80 % de
l'export de la région c'est en ver des
pays de l'Union européen ça veut dire
que euh au contraire dans notre cas euh
l'adhésion à l'Union Européen se fait
déjà progressive et bien sûr que on
espère maintenant d'avoir plusieurs
chapitres ouverts avec une autre vitesse
à
l'adhésion sur l'opinion publique euh
c'est clair que il a des différentses
opinions mais euh de même façon si on a
commencé déjà des discussions pour nous
euh ça reste aussi un élément euh
d'introduire des nouveaux arguments
positifes de qu'est-ce que peut apporter
la Moldavie c'est pour ça que j'ai
mentionné du début que la Moldavie ne
demande pas d'être simplement un membre
mais il demande d'être accepté et euh
euh il va devenir un membre euh solide
de même façon la Moldavie déjà contribue
à l'Union Européen par assurant la
sécurité à la frontière avec l'Ukraine
et la Roumanie dommagement on parle pas
trop que la Moldavie déjà ass sur la
sécurité régionale parce que comme vous
le savez très bien c'est très compliqué
d'assurer pour un pays nutre euh qui n'a
pas investi dans dans
l'armée pendant 30 ans d'avoir d'un côté
la frontière avec le crin
d'avoir le conflit transnistrien avec un
présence militaire russe et de même
façon d'
la protection à la frontière à à la
Roumanie avec la frontière avec la
Roumanie membres de l'Union Européen et
de l'OTAN mais dans ce sens-là on a déjà
en exercice la mission du Frontex qui
nous aide énormément pour assurer cette
sécurité et de même façon euh les
dernières 2 ans on a vraiment des
exercices communes euh avec les pays
membres de l'Union européenne euh et euh
par exemple l'organisation du sommet de
la communauté politique européen c'est
déjà aussi un exercice commune d'assurer
la sécurité et la protection entre les
pays membres de l'Union européenne et
plutôt la France et la Moldavie
euh et ça dans cet esprit euh c'est
clair que l'intégration européen
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne se
fait pas seulement en Moldavie mais se
fait aussi dans les les pays membres de
l'Union Européen et c'est notre
responsabilité commune euh d'être ouvert
d'avoir des débats publics en expliquant
que on vient pas pour affaiblir l'Union
Européen mais au contraire pour faire
que l'Union Européen soit plus fort de
même façon on a déjà un millions de
moldaves à l'étrangère
euh et je crois que ici aussi c'est très
important de mentionner que la plupart
sont dans les pays membres de l'Union
européenne aussi en France et ils sont
déjà des contribuables à tout ce que ça
signifie les valeurs
européennes en Moldavie l'opinion
publique
euh c'est aussi assez fort comme vous le
savez le 17 mai cette année on a
organisé une grande assemblée pour le
soutien du l'objectif d'intégration
européenne mais c'était très important
pour nous
car cette assemblée a été répliquée dans
plusieurs capitales membres de l'Union
européenne par les citoyens par le
diaspora aussi ici à Paris et ça reste
et comme j'ai j'ai mentionné déjà avant
l'objectif d'être membre de l'Union
Européen c'est déjà un objective sans
euh aucun euh
euh c'est clair pour tous que le pays
peut se transformer en étant membre d'un
partenaire d'une organisation forte et
solide euh l'OTAN bien sûr que l'opinion
publique en Moldavie s'était très
concentrée sur le fait que on est pays
neutre
neutralité confirmée par la Constitution
euh de même façon la guerre en nukra et
et et et
toute les dernières évolutions ça a
changé l'opinion publque mais pour
l'instant ça sera
trop trop rapide de dire
si on va rester dans un euh dans un
statut statut ou dans l'autre de l'autre
côté
euh si jamais pour nous déjà la la
réforme des des structures du du
maintien de du sécurité c'est déjà clair
parce que
euh pour la première fois dans la la
société on a commencé de discuter euh de
la réforme de l'armée seulement l'année
passée depuis l'année est passé jusqu'à
maintenant déjà beaucoup de choses se
passent euh c'est dans cet esprit qui
s'inscrit aussi la coopération dans le
demand
du de l'armée entre la Moldavie et la
France dans 30 ans on n' eu jamais aucun
contact et euh novembre l'année passée
on a eu le la visite de notre ministre
de la Défense ici à Paris le 25
septembre le ministre Sébastien Cornu le
Cornu se sont pass à kishenau et
maintenant on va avoir un accord de
coopération dans le domaine militaire
c'est déjà des étapes très claires que
la Moldavie a changé l'optique mais déjà
sur des autres
aspects ça va prendre un peu du temps
mais c'est très clair que l'opinion
publique ça ça a changé euh
migration c'est un sujet très difficile
parce que comme un million de moldaves
sont déjà à l'étran re ça se pose
toujours la question est-ce qu'on va
réussir de convaincre que le moldave
revient en Moldavie ou on se concentre
de motivé que les Moldaves qui sont en
Moldavie qui restent en Moldavie et et
finalement toutes les réformes toutes
les transformations mais
aussi toutes les
investissements et la transformation
économique de Moldavie ça va assurer
aussi que le moldave reste en Moldavie
et contribue au développement du pays à
l'intérieur du pays et pas seulement du
de l'étrangère et on a de signes du du
retour de même façon il a des nouveaux
programmes pour diaspora pour les
encourager d'investir en Moldavie euh et
maintenant il y a déjà des des progrès
dans ce sens-là mais plutôt la
transformation économique du du pays ça
va aussi rassurer que le moldave reste
au niveau du pays le conflit
transnistrien pour la mold mavie
toujours ça a été très important d'avoir
un réglementation pacifique et que la
Moldavie soit réintégré avec la région
transnistrienne aujourd'hui bien sûr que
c'est un obstacle mais euh pendant
toutes les années et aussi aujourd'hui
ça ça reste d'avoir un dialogue entre
kishina et tiraspul sur les sujets et
les les problèmes quotidiens pour nous
ça reste aussi et comme je j'ai
mentionnais euh l'accord compréhensive
de libre échange ça déjà rapproche euh
les les les deux parties et ça va rester
par des différentses mesures et à peu
près il a plusieurs projets de l'Union
européenne qui sont mis en œuvre aussi
pour la région on n'a eu jamais euh
cette euh distinction très abrupte au
contraire
euh l'idée c'était que
avec la vitesse d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne on ser plus solide et
finalement c'est pas un conflit entre la
population euh c'est un conflit qui
existe mais c'est pas le problème
entre moral
entre les citoyens on espère que avec le
progrès et
avec la solution
et plutôt avec une une solution positive
de la guerre en utrance ça ça sera
impacté aussi une solution positive pour
la région transnistrien et pour la
Moldavie
entière
euh Partenariat oriental
euh jusqu'à maintenant on a bénéficié de
plusieurs projets et euh je crois que le
Partenariat oriental a réalisé les
objectifs parce que euh deux pays dans
ce cas Moldavie et l'Ukraine a obtenu
ils ont obtenu le statut de candidature
à l'Union européen mais plusieurs
transformations se sont passées grâce au
projet du Partenariat oriental bien sûr
que si on on on va lancer les
négociations d'adhésion pour nous c'est
très clair que ce format devrait se
changer ou comment la République de
Moldavie se peut retrouver dans dans
dans le partenariat mais pour l'instant
c'est clair que les projets qui sont
jusqu'à
2i27 seront mis en œuvre mais euh
comment ça va trans former impacter
euh le partenariat c'est un peu en tout
cas on demande la révision euh le triot
Raine géographie Moldavie il y est il va
rester mais déjà dans le temps on va
voir qu'est-ce que peut se passer mais
pour l'instant ça ça reste
et nous on est très solidaire avec
l'ukrain et tout ce que se
passe au niveau du du sécuritaire
communauté
tiqueéne la salle d'attente vous avez
dit et bien pour nous ce n'était pas
vraiment une salle d'attente la
plateforme nous permet en fait d'avoir
un dialogue concret de façon immédiate
et dans notre cas cela va prendre
probablement 10 ans puisque on nous a
demandé pour la première
fois
euh les euh taxes d'itinérance et nous
avons reçu un très grand soutien de la
France pour toutes les mesures et donc
pour nous en fin de compte il s'agit
d'une plateforme très
concrète qui va nous permettre qui va
nous appuyer dans la prise de décision
beaucoup alors on va passer vous avez
déjà été très précise dans la plupart de
vos questions donc je sais que certaines
sont partagées avec nos sénateurs c'est
ira peut-être plus vite du côté des
sénateurs donc et je vais commencer par
nos rapporteurs élargissement donc
Martha Sidrac et Didier Marie comme tout
à l'heure oui bien sûr merci monsieur le
Président mes questions seront très
rapides madame l'ambassadrice euh en
fait la première concerne le peuple
moldave tout simplement je crois que
c'est Monsieur Giuliani qui disait qu'en
fait l'adhésion ne peut se faire sans
les peuples j'avais une question
concernant la en fait les passeports
moldaves on sait que beaucoup de vos
concitoyens sont également roumains pour
des raisons qui s'expliquent donc qui
sont en réalité aujourd'hui européens
donc je dirais cette population là
qu'attend-elle en réalité de l'adhésion
de l'Union européenne excusez-moi de
cette question peut-être un peu naïve
mais j'aurais aimé vous entendre
là-dessus ma deuxième cons la concerne
votre diaspora vous avez évoqué la
diaspora aujourd'hui moldave qui est
dans au sein de l'Union européenne vous
n'avez pas évoqué la diaspora moldave
qui est en Russie aussi puisque vous
avez aussi une diaspora russe
aujourd'hui et j'aurais souhaité aussi
que connaître ce que vous pouvez nous
dire de leur opinion notamment avec le
conflit enfin le conflit la guerre que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui en
Ukraine comment cette cette diaspora en
Russie cette diaspora moldave qui je
suppose à vocation également à devenir
européenne demain a peut-être ou pas une
influence dans l'opinion publique je
vous remercie merci
Didier ça fonctionne vous avez répondu
aux questions que je me souhaitais vous
poser sur le conflit gel en Transnistrie
euh et et donc j'aurais voulu que vous n
donniez quelques élément
d'information sur la situation en en
gagaouzi euh qui était un élément de
crispation politique aussi relativement
significatif ces derniers temps et
et peut-être aussi que vous nous
précisiez quels sont aujourd'hui les
éléments d'influence de la Russie euh
dans le pays et et euh si le
positionnement euh
des oligarques qui se sont exilés reste
un un problème pour l'équilibre
politique du pays enfin dernière
question très rapide et extrêmement
simple euh combien de temps vous donnez
pour adhérer à l'Union
européenne alors on passe aux questions
des sénateurs alors il m'a déjà demandé
la parole hier soir pour ce matin Alain
Cadec mais je sais que la question qu'il
voulait poser a a trouvé sa réponse la
réponse peut-être pas mais la question
était
posé excellence oui excellence je
voulais évoquer merci monsieur le
Président d'abord mais ça a été évoqué
déjà par plusieurs
intervenant c'est le le problème de la
Transnistrie et et et comment la
Moldavie pense régler ce ce ce ce
problème parce que c'est un problème
puisque elle est peuplée majoritairement
de russophone enfin il y en a à peu près
un gros tiers un peu plus d'un tiers euh
et donc c région à cette particularité
et et et va sûrement poser problème dans
le cadre d'une intégration à l'Union
européenne donc come comment la
Moldavie pense gérer cette cette
situation qui nous semble à nous très
compliquée c'est tout claud K et André
richchard
oui merci président comme tout le monde
la la question principale que j'avais
puisque vous connaissez mon intérêt
madame l'ambassadrice et et ma mission
au sein de la PCE sur les conflits gelés
cette question a été largement abordée
en ce qui concerne la Transnistrie et
cette situation nous aurons encore
l'occasion d'en d'en discuter
prochainement donc je je ne vais pas
m'étendre
là-dessus parmi les différentes réformes
législative que vous avez mise en œuvre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où vous
en êtes avec la réforme de la justice et
surtout dans le processus de recrutement
et des garanties d'indépendance des
juges
André
Richard merci président
euh je vais synthétiser autant que
possible les interventions de de de mes
collègues précédents euh par une
question très directe qui concerne
l'accessibilité l'enthousiasme l'accueil
je sais pas quel terme utilisé euh par
la population moldave de cette
candidature au sein de l'Union
européenne
je vais je vous je vais vous poser une
question très presque provocatrice
madame l'ambassadeur euh
50 % à peu près les chiffres qui m'ont
été donnés euh varient entre 40 et 60
donc je vais dire 50 50 % de la
population moldave a d'ors et déjà un
passeport européen ça a été dit ils sont
européens puisquils sont euh roumains
ils ont le passeport roumain ils ont le
passeport moldave euh au au nord au
nord-est il y a la Transnistrie on en a
parlé euh
russophone dans le sud gagaouzi euh
plutôt au russophone moins que la
transistrie puisqu'il y a celle-ci a
déclaré son entre guillemets autonomie
donc on me dit que entre les 50 et les
100 % c'est 25 % transistrie 25 %
gagaouzi je va pas vérifier donc
euh voilà vous avez compris 50 % est
déjà dans l'Union européenne les deux
autres 25 % 50 % ont pas franchement
envie d'y aller puisqu'ils sont ils sont
rusophones alors ma question très
provocatrice quelle peut-être dans ces
conditionsl l'accueil l'enthousiasme je
reprends mes termes la volonté véritable
de la population moldave d'intégrer
l'Union européenne c'était vous l'avez
compris c'était c'était c'était une
question vraiment pour le
fun madame l'ambassadrice à vous pour
euh 5
minutes diaspora euh oui c'est un
million de moldaves à l'étrangère il y a
dans les pays de l'Union européenne et
il y a en Russie ça ça reste les
citoyens moldaves euh finalement
euh le diaspora a indiquer dans les
élections du 2021 que leur vote c'est
pour
l'objectif pour la démocratisation pour
la transformation du pays et le vote du
diaspora a donné aussi un impact pour
les résultats final des élections à
Moldavie et je crois que avec ça c'est
très clair que la plupart de la
population reste toujours adhérant à un
projet national du du PAI et d'être
membre de l'Union Européen euh pour nous
ça n'importe où ils se trouve euh ils
sont les citoyens moldaves avec
différentses opinions et comme j'ai j'ai
mentionné du début la Moldavie a réussi
de construire un modèle Pacifique
d'existence de plusieurs ethnies euh
avec leur acceptation avec leur
intégration sans aucuns éléments et et
finalement
euh l'opinion publique du diaspora ça
c'est c'est un argument très fort euh
mais il existe partout
euh euh
différentses opinions mais la plupart je
réitère encore fois ils ont fait leur
choix par soutenant euh le changement du
pays rapprochement en verers du de
l'Union européenne
oui c'est vrai qu'en Moldavie on a la
région transnistrien et on a la l'unité
territoriale administrative de gagaouzi
euh en gagoui cette année où on a eu les
élections euh pour le
gouverneur d'après les dernières et
d'après toutes les investigations euh
ils ont constaté que plusieurs euh
personnes qui ont voté euh ils ont été
influencés et pour l'instant l'enquête
encore est en place et à ce motif là
euh la décision
et le décret
présidentiel pour la nomination du
gouverneur il était pas encore signé euh
par la présidente euh mais finalement ça
reste
euh un débat sérieux euh d'après euh
l'exprimation du vote des citoyens de la
région par voie simple libre transparent
et pas sous les influences des
différents éléments
euh l'influence euh du la Russie ou
généralement la situation en Moldavie
comme vous le savez on a eu euh euh le
mois de novembre les élections
locales mais pour la Moldavie c'est pas
seulement le défi d'avoir un guerre à la
frontière mais aussi euh un guerre
hybride et la désinformation la
propagande constante euh 80 % du médiia
TV jusqu'à l'année passée s'était
retransmis de du Russie et à la fin de
l'année passée avec les modifications
législatives mais aussi d'après toutes
les rapports euh euh et avec la décision
du Conseil audiovisuel 6 canal
retransmis 6 canal russe retransmis
fédéral retransmis en Moldavie ils ont
été suspendus et d'après les les
dernières décisions aussi du de la
Commission sur la situation
exceptionnelle en Moldavie aussi
plusieurs canal ils ont été suspendus
temporairement du notre territoire et
c'est vraiment très compliqué de faire
face à à toute la
désinformation pour la Moldavie le plus
compliqué que le le code audiovisuel
prévoit seulement le contrôle du média
classique écrite TV et radio et pas
online et à ce motif là euh les
autorités ils ont venu avec l'initiative
de créer on a créé le centre de
communication
stratégique qui qui vient seulement de
nommer leur nouveau directeur et ici
c'est aussi un des éléments où on va
travailler avec la France tenant compte
de toute l'expertise qui a été déjà mise
en œuvre mais ça reste un défi très
constant très solide
euh très inquiétant parce que la
désinformation
euh ça reste d'être très présent et
comme je dis on nétait pas très bien on
n'a pas développé on n' pas réussi
d'avoir plusieurs outils pour faire face
à toute la campagne de de
désinformation comme vous le savez euh
au niveau du Parlement on a deux partis
d'opposition le Parti socialiste et le
parti ch qui a été déclaré non
constitutionnel
euh le président du du ce parti qui a
été déclaré coupable pour la fraude
bancaire se trouve en Israël les
autorités ils ont demandé l'extradition
pour l'instant la situation reste comme
il reste euh euh avec cette opposition
qui qui qui a euh le droit à l'opinion
mais qui qui fasse et qui dont aussi
plusieurs euh aspects inquiétants pour
les autorités pour faire face à toutes
les arguments et toutes les les actions
qui qui sont mis au niveau du
pays la région transnistrienne et
généralement le conflit transnistriin
euh les autorités toujours se sont
attachées à la solution euh et de
trouver la solution pacifique de ce
conflit dans le format 5+2 comme vous
comprenez très bien le format 5 + 2
aujourd'hui ne peut pas se réunir tenant
compte du fait que deux pays deux
parties sont bgérantes euh mais pour
nous ça reste toujours que euh c'est pas
euh je reviens sur l'argument c'est pas
un conflit entre la population au
contraire dans la région ça reste euh
des écoles sous notre administration il
y a des personnes qui travaillent de
notre côté mais il habit de de l'autre
côté si je reviens sur la citité
plusieurs personnes qui habitent dans la
région ils ont aussi la citité romain et
finalement c'est pas
euh le projet de transformation du pays
euh le fait de vivre en paix c'est le
choix de la population et euh sans euh
distinction
euh l'unité territoriale administrative
de gagouzi ou la
Transnistrie tous nous on a des
relatives dans les les deux régions qui
qui est notre territoire qui est notre
pays et euh euh je crois que c'est plus
sage d'éviter cette distinction entre
les territoires parce que finalement la
Moldavie devrait se réintégrer et d'être
fort avec
toutes les partis qui à un moment de
donné ils ont eu cette
mais ce passage mais ça reste d'être que
nous tous nous on est un pays intègre
bien sûr on veut d'être plus rapide
réintégré avec la région transnistrien
mais comme je dis c'est un processus
graduel qui a commencé euh parce qu'il a
pas aucun ou comme je disais euh quand
on a négocié l'accord compréhensive de
coopération économique avec l'Union
Européen on n' pas pensé seulement à
kichenau aux autorités de kichenau mais
c'était déjà prévu les mesures pour la
région transnistrien et par ça
euh pour le régime libéralisé de visa
c'est aussi les citoyens qui habitent
dans la région transnistrienne qui ont
un un passeport moldave qui voyage aussi
aujourd'hui
euh en Europe ou dans les autres pays et
finalement
euh ça reste d'être cette région mais je
crois que avec la sagesse et avec la
diplomatie avec le dialogue on peut
arriver de résoudre le conflit et que ça
se pose pas comme un grand souci ni pour
nous ni pour les partenaires ni pour la
France ni pour l'Union européenne
réforme de la justice et lutte contre la
corruption comme vous le savez c'était
la priorité numéro 0 de la président du
nouveau gouvernement et du Parlement ça
ça ça a mis beaucoup
d'effort mais je reviens sur le fait que
on a attendu 10 ans pour changer la
constitution et plutôt la provision sur
la nomination des juges auprès du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature ça
c'était aussi un projet qui a
pris plusieurs années mais qui a été
possible grâce au partenariat oriental
au support de l'Union Européen et au
Conseil de l'Europe et on a réussi
d'adopter cette modification grâce à
cette modification aujourd'hui euh en
Moldavie il y a le le le système de
prévting euh la vérification de toutes
les candidats pour la position du juge
au niveau du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature un conseil qui déjà est
fonctionnel au niveau de la Cour
supérieure de la justice et au niveau du
Conseil supérieur des procureurs
[Musique]
euh au niveau du
l'accessibilité comme je disais euh il y
a différentses opinions ça c'est vrai
mais le projet de transformation du pays
et d'adhésion à l'Union européenne c'est
un projet national et dans le
contexte avec la guerre plutôt ça a
donné une autre vitesse
et la
compréhension plus rapide que il faut le
faire plus rapide possible pour rester
au sent des valeurs et sans un guerre
les opinions euh et c'est normal d'avoir
des différentses opinions mais c'est
aussi notre devoir de le plus de le
transformer parce que finalement la
population demande d'avoir une une vie
euh
plus plus acceptable aujourd'hui et pas
demain c'est pour ça que notre rôle de
diplomats se sont transformés aussi euh
le support politique et diplomatique qui
existe aujourd'hui pour la Moldavie
c'est sans précédent jamais on a eu un
un tel support et un tel support
extraordinaire de la France pour la
Moldavie mais pour nous euh euh c'est
très important de transformer ce support
dans les actions plus concrètes que la
population comprend qu'est-ce que ça
signifie le rapprochement du de l'Union
Européen c'est pour ça qu'on a insisté
et on est très reconnaissant à la France
pour le support donner d'avoir l'accord
sur les frais d'itinérance c'est pour ça
qu'on demande la reconnaissance des
permis de conduire moldave pour les
citoyens moldaves qui travaillent
temporairement ou euh qui voyagent en
Europe et en France en particulier sans
avoir des des différents soucis mais
mais finalement le projet européen pour
nous aujourd'hui c'est aussi la
transformation et les résultats concrets
qu'on le don à la population pour
comprendre mieux qu'est-ce que ça
signifie l'Union Européen et c'est pas
seulement des mots parce que dommagement
euh euh il y a la désinformation
en disant que oui vous pouvez parler
beaucoup de choses mais comment ça se
transforme comment ça affecte notre vie
et je crois que par des choses très
concrètes on peut réaliser un passage
une adhésion graduelle positive de la
Moldavie envers de l'Union Européen
combien du temps c'est un peu compliqué
je peux pas m'engager de dire ça bon au
niveau politique à Moldavie on a eu
plusieurs opinions euh personnellement
comme juriste comme économiste je reste
d'être optimiste plutôt que ça sera fait
plus rapide possible et que les Moldaves
se sonent vraiment
euh fi de transformer le pays mais aussi
d'être membr de l'Union
européenne merci beaucoup madame
l'ambassadrice c'était très très
précis et je redis avec fierté si notre
commission a peut contribuer dans ces
gchanges à à per permettre justement
l'accession données mobiles au roaming
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le
roaming voilà je je trahis
encore ma langue mais voilà je pense que
c'est c'est une des premières étapes qui
et puis je pense aussi que l'engagement
de votre présidente est important pour
l'avoir rencontré plusieurs fois on sent
très bien que ça sa
volonté sa cité font que c'est quand
même encourageant pour le futur merci
beaucoup
merci bon on tient à peu
près
bra
allons-y bon on est sur un format assez
contraint Monsieur l'Ambassadeur on vous
a expliqué vous prenez la parole pour 5
minutes
ensite
alors pas de pause publicitaire on
enchaîne
oui donc format
contra
bien merci de repositionner Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur nous avons souhaité faire
le point sur la perspective européenne
de votre pays la Commission européenne
dans son rapport publié le 8 novembre
dernier recommande en effet au Conseil
européen de lui reconnaître le statut de
candidat et celui-ci devrait se
prononcer dans sa prochaine réunion qui
a lieu mi-décembre ardent militant de la
cause européenne de votre pays vous
maîtrisez parfaitement notre langue et
notre culture puisque vous avez grandi
en France vous connaissez les liens
anciens d'amitié qui unissent le Sénat
et la Géorgie nous avons reçu cette
année la présidente de la commission de
l'intégration européenne du Parlement
geéorgien madame macab
borichevil que j'ai revu que nous avons
vu il y a il y a 48h à à Madrid
également francophone ainsi que le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de votre Parlement monsieur
Sam carazzé
dans son rapport la Commission
européenne soulligne que la Géorgie a
intensifié ses réformes pour se
rapprocher de l'Union européenne
notamment dans les domaines de l'égalité
des sexes et de la lutte contre les
violences à l'égard des femmes et la
criminalité organisée aussi la
commission recommande-t-elle de lui
accorder officiellement le statut de
pays candidat sous certaines conditions
permettez-moi d'insister sur
l'importance pour votre pays de
démontrer son attachement profond et
stable aux valeurs de l'Union européenne
et l'effectivité de l'État de droit dans
une période où la polarisation politique
semble importante avant les élections
législatives de l'an prochain Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur vous avez la parole pour 5
minutes puis nous entendrons à nouveau
nos experts chacun de à 3 minutes et
nous engagerons le dialogue avec les
sénateurs je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Mesdames
et monsieurs le sénateur sénatrice c'est
un c'est un honneur pour moi de de me
présenter devant vous
avec pour résumer un peu le parcours
européen de de mon pays surtout les
aspirations les aspirations à devenir à
terme naturellement membres de cette
famille européenne nous vivons
actuellement dans une époque extrêmement
mouvontée le monde entier l'architecture
de la sécurité internationale sont en
train d'être remodelé et la table ronde
d'aujourd'hui sur l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne faisant suite aux
discussions informelles sur l'avenir de
l'Europe
lancé récemment à Grenade en octobre et
AR arrive à point même à point nommé je
dirais même que ces discussions sont
indispensables dans cette optique c'est
un honneur naturellement pour moi de
contribuer à ce
processus au nom de la ie qui aspire à
devenir européenne comme je l'ai
souligné l'Union européenne se trouve
dans un tournant critique dans le
contexte de la refonte de son rôle en
tant qu'acteur mondial en réponse au
changement drastique du contexte
géopolitique de la région dû à la guerre
d'agression de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine c'est la situation que nous
avons connu malheureusement au mois
d'août 2008 c'est donc les Georges sont
d'autant plus bien placés si on peut
dire comme ça pour comprendre l'atrocité
de cette guerre et pour dénoncer
justement l'injustice de de cette guerre
et aussi à quel point nous
sommes nous sommes vigilants nous sommes
soucieux à ce que l'Ukraine gagne cette
guerre parce que nous connaissons les
résultats des conflit gelé qui renforce
surtout le dans ses positions la Russie
et c'est d'autant plus cette
mobilisation de la solidarité
internationale est très très importante
pour pour ne pas laisser l'Ukraine seule
dans dans cette guerre les changements
géopolitiques accélérés ont démontré la
nécessité absolu de consolider
l'ensemble et la volonté le pouvoir pour
une Union européenne plus forte le futur
élargissement qui connaît actuellement
un élan remarquable est une réponse
stratégique et puissante à cet égard
l'un des plus grands pouvoirs en effet
de transformation de l'Union européenne
a toujours été son outil d'élargissement
avec un puissant potentiel de promotion
et d'expansion des valeurs et des normes
démocratiques il n'est fait aucun doute
que cela apporte cela apportera aussi
une plus grande résilience à nos pays
individuellement et collectivement
renforçant ainsi l'un ainsi l'Union
européenne en tant qu'acteur mondial sur
ce ce point permettez-moi de souligner
que la
Géorgie a toujours été et resterint un
allié
sécuritaire un des plus fiables de
l'Union européenne contribuant à la
sécurité et à la stabilité de de ses
partenaires un rempart de paix et de
stabilité régionale de développement
démocratique et de coopération servant
de lien crucial dans la politique de la
porte d'entrée mondiale de l'Union
européenne et promouvant
l'approvisionnement en énergie alter
natif et les couloirs de
transport comme l'a démontré la
dépendance du chemin emprunté chaque
vague d'élargissement de l'Union
européenne précédit d'ajustement
institutionnel pertinent qui a renforcé
l'Union européenne la Georgie en tant
que membre de l'actuel groupe
d'élargissement est très intéressé par
la réalisation d'un juste équilibre
entre l'Union européenne élargie et
Union européenne qui fonctionne
efficacement comme vous savez nous avons
la Georgie a investi dans ses efforts
considérables dans la réforme des
principaux cadres politique et juridique
et dans la mise en place de nouvelles
institutions conformément aux
engagements pris dans le cadre de
l'accord d'association y compris
l'accord en libre échange et les 12
recommandations qui nous a été donné par
la Commission européenne que nous
appelons parfois affectueusement les 12
commandements de l'Union européenne
auquel nous essayons de de de
répondre alors que le rapprochement
juridique et sectoriel de la geéorgie
avec l'Union européenne se poursuit à la
grande vitesse et en gardant à l'esprit
que le concept de d'une intégration
progressive semble être la voie à suivre
par rapport à l'élargissement nous
aimerions appeler à l'élaboration des
programmes concrets d'intégration
progressive dans l'Union européenne qui
garantiront une synchronisation du
processus euh et menant une adhésion
complète puisque nous nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de temps je je raccourcirai ce
que je je je voulais je voulais dire
pour dire aussi que nous ne voulons pas
seulement réaliser des réformes
démocratiques pour cocher les cases de
des recommandations et des conseils que
nous recevons de nos partenaires
européennes mais également c'est dans le
souci de vouloir se doter d'un pays
extrêmement démocratique et fidèle aux
valeurs valeurs européennes que nous
voulons réaliser tout toutes ces
réformes naturellement le l'objectif
étant d'adhérer à terme l'Union
européenne pour nous comme vous l'aurez
compris c'est une question sécuritaire
mais salutaire dans le contexte
géopolitique dans lequel nous nous
trouvons de bénéf de pouvoir bénéficier
dans seulement cette stabilité politique
mais également être toujours vigilant à
à garder cette cap de
d'intégration de la politique européenne
de d'avoir des réformes économique aussi
qui nous permettra d'avoir une économie
stable
pour pour répondre aussi aux exigences
et critères de convergence connu de pour
pour être membre de l'Union européenne
dans l'avenir et puis aussi pour vous
dire que les Georgiens sont réalistes et
regarde cette perspective avec un
sentiment de de réalisme nous savons si
je peux me permettre comme on dit en
France en français ce n'est pas demain
la veille avec le le statut de candidat
qu'on adhéra à parentir l'Union
européenne mais n serit-ce que garder
cette cap dans la population de
maintenir la population sur cet axe sur
cette voie de l'intégration est une très
bonne chose et c'est un signal aussi
donc il y aurait les deux les deux
formes
de signaux envoyés à la Russie pour
pourquoi cacher le le nom de d'un d'un
voisin
qui qui nous envoie d'autres signaux
aussi donc si de la part de l'Union
européenne à
accorder le statut candidat et
travailler sur l'élargissement de nos
trois pays ce qu'on appelle troïca qui
les pays Balcans aussi naturellement
enfin ils ont mérit aussi de de faire
partie de l'Union européenne euh c'est
c'est de dire de la part de l'Europe que
l'Europe est là et l'Europe s'intéresse
à cette région la mer Noire est une zone
géopolitique très importante pour pour
l'Union européenne pour ne pas la
laisser seulement comme zone de
prédilection de certains grands pays
qui qui prétendent qui ont prétendu
jusqu'à présent être les seuls
propriétaires les seuls patron de de la
du bassin de la mer Noire mais il y a
d'autres pays aussi qui qui sont
acteurs
incontournable du bassin de la mer Noire
et aussi ce ça pourrait être un signal
aussi très négatif de dire oui
aujourd'hui il y a encore il faut mieux
se préparer et remettre les échéances à
à plus à quelques années plus tard ça
serait un signal à la Russie de dire que
voilà on vous laisse la Georgie
faites-en ce que vous voulez donc c'est
ce serait ça serait un signe de de
manque de l'intérêt de de la part de
l'Europe voilà je vous remercie je
j'aurais pu encore
l'occasion je pense en répondant en
répondant aux différentes questions en
rappelant je je le rappelle à nos
interlocuteurs différents et et au prise
ceux qui vont prendre la parole que nous
sommes filmés en vidéo sur le site du
Sénat je le rappelle toujours parce que
c'est c'est important de le savoir et ça
fait une petite promotion au Sénat oui
monsieur Marie je sais il fait froid
dans cette
salle nous sommes au premiier loge du la
propulsion d'air froid
euh nous laissons donc la parole à nos
experts monsieur Juliani dans le même
ordre merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur comme je disais pour
connaître votre pays je sais que le
choix pour l'Europe c'est un choix du
peuple est-ce que c'est le choix aussi
de toutes les élites je pense aux
oligarques et je pense même à un certain
oligarqu est-il un frein à ce
rapprochement vers l'Union européenne
je disais tout à l'heure aussi trop
rapidement combien vous venez de le
répéter le le rapprochement de l'Europe
c'est aussi la transformation des pays
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
donner un signal pour aider à cette
transformation qui est en cours ma
troisème réflexion sera plus destinée à
mes compatriotes
français je considère qu'en
2008 mon pays la France l'Allemagne
aussi commis une grave erreur euh à
Bucharest en fermant la porte à
l'adhésion de l'OTAN 4 mois plus tard
euh une partie de votre pays a été
occupé
euh trois pays euh dont nous avons parlé
ce matin sont partiellement occupés par
la Russie il est temps comme vous le
disiez d'envoyer un signal sur lequel
par lequel nous refusons euh cette euh
politique impérialiste expansionniste
révisionniste et d'agression vous allez
trouver monsieur le Président que j'en
fais une
fixation c'est surtout une
inquiétude liberté des
propos monsieur
Chopin merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
pour pour vos propos en écho à ce qui
vient d'être dit par jeanominique
Juliani moi aussi j'aimerais peut-être
insister d'abord sur sur ce que vous
avez dit sur la géopolitisation de
l'Europe et l'élargissement comme
réponse stratégique en fait à cette
question dans sa dimension notamment
sécuritaire je pense aussi que c'est
c'est évidemment un élément fondamental
et je suis plutôt d'accord avec cette
cette approche en fait ce qui est ce qui
est intéressant et en même temps
peut-être ce qui pose question pour un
public français c'est que
l'élargissement pour le dire autrement
comme un élément de la puissance
européenne présentons les choses comme
ça est un élément qui qui est assez
orthogonal avec une position française
traditionnelle qui perçoit classiquement
en fait l'élargissement comme étant
opposé à un approfondissement politique
ou géopolitique donc comment essayer de
lever en fait cette cette difficulté là
qui est sans doute un obstacle en fait
important en tout cas pour favoriser
l'appropriation de la perspective de de
l'adhésion à terme d'un pays comme la
Géorgie à à l'Union européenne la 2ème
chose euh euh ma 2ème question en fait
porte sur ce que vous avez dit mais vous
n'avez pas eu le temps de de développer
ce point donc la question peut peut-être
vous vous donné l'occasion de de le
faire vous avez évoqué euh la
perspective d'une adhésion progressive
en vue d'une adhésion complète à l'Union
européenne et vous avez mis l'accent sur
l'importance de programmes concrets mais
vous n'avez pas mentionné lesquels donc
quels seraiit pour vous en fait les les
programmes concrets en question euh qui
serait jugé prioritaire par votre pays
dans le domaine économique dans le
domaine politique dans le domaine
stratégique si vous pouvez nous en dire
un peu plus sur ce point ça ça serait
sans doute très utile merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur chopa Monsieur matchek
Merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur ce que les médias ont
essentiellement retenu de du paquet de
d'élargissement de la Commission sur la
gegie c'est la recommandation mais ce
qui était peut-être un peu moins vu
c'est que c'est une recommandation
conditionnelle et par ailleurs il m'a
semblé en écoutant la présidente de la
commission expliquer face au
journalistes cette décision qui étit en
partie considéré comme une relative
surprise j'ai l'impression qu'elle a
quand même très largement souligner le
fait que cette recommandation était une
façon de reconnaître l'engagement
européen comme disait monsieur Giuliani
du peuple sans que ce soit une caution
ou ou une forme de satisfaite qui serait
donné au gouvernement
donc je voudrais rejoindre la question
qui était déjà posée en en appuyant un
peu sur ce point qui pour le coup me me
semble on-il fait une spécificité euh en
tout cas sur entre guillemets le trio
oriental de la Géorgie par rapport aux
deux autres pays qui font l'objet de de
cette table ronde d'aujourd'hui euh par
ailleurs je je voulais poser la même
question que que Thierry Chupin a posé
je voudrais juste peut-être ajouter un
élément donc effectivement concrètement
quelles sont pour vous les priorités
quell pourrait être les premières
pierres concrète à poser dans cet
édifice d'une d'une adhésion graduelle
de la Géorgie à l'Union européenne mais
j'ajouterai juste une chose aussi quels
sont les gestes politiques fort geste
symbolique fort que à votre avis le
gouvernement georgien est prêt à faire
aussi pour quelque part donner un
certain nombre de de de de gage de sa
volonté justement
de de réduire cet écart perçu en tout
cas me semble-t-il par beaucoup de
d'observateurs entre l'opinion publique
et et le gouvernement euh voilà merci
beaucoup monsieur oui per
permettez-mexcuser pour prendre le train
en marche mais l'Union européenne en
regarde un petit peu l'expérience dans
les Balcans a parfois fait montre
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'une certaine
complaisance
euh en matière de de de dans pour des
motifs géopolitiques en matière de de
soutien à des élites qui parfois
effectivement sont été très douteus le
cas Montenegro par exemple où l'Union
européenne a soutenu un un régime parce
qu'il était très transatlantique cé
également le cas aujourd'hui en Serbie
où on ferme les yeux sur certaines
choses les réactions de la société
civile de ces pays nous apprennent que
que que que certaines forces demandent
davantage de sanctionner les élites
quand elles ne ne s ne s'engage pas euh
favorablement plutôt que de d'espérer
qu'une politique d'apaisement apaisement
se traduisent par par de bons résultats
d'où ma question que pensez-vous de ces
idées de réversibilité euh dans les
réformes de processus d'adhésion que
l'on met sur la table la réversibilité
existe déjà en pratique euh enfin dans
les faits euh mais est-ce selon vous
quelque chose qui devrait être davantage
appliqué quitte à ce que cela sanctionne
d'une certaine façon des États dont les
élites sont plutôt partagées la deuxième
chose c'est que le processus
d'élargissement est un processus de
cooptation plus encore peut-être qu'un
processus de convergence un processus de
cooptation par les
États-membres ça aide d'avoir des parins
ou des amis on comprend facilement que
que que nos amis ukrainiens ont de forts
soutien notamment dans les pays en les
pays baltes en Europe centrale et
orientale la Moldavie on pense à la
Roumanie forcément et à la France la
Géorgie quel serait votre votre allié le
plus le plus influent au sein de l'Union
européenne que vous pourriez cibler
dernière question l'intégration
européenne forcément c'est les valeurs
on le comprend bien la population
l'engagement mais c'est également un
projet politique un projet politique et
là-dessus la question a été a été déjà
posée par elanora précédemment quelle
est votre vision du du projet po
politique européen est-ce pour vous
quelque chose qui inspire le fédéralisme
est-ce quelque chose qui va qui inspire
une forme de souverainisme des nations
un grand
marché une idée de souveraineté
européenne voyez les différents modèles
les différentes visions dont on discute
au sein de l'Union européenne quelle est
la vision de votre pays dans ce débat
sur sur l'avenir de l'Europe
oui monsieur
beaucoup je vais vous poser la question
l'anglais si vous pouvez répondre bien
sûr en français merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur pour de nombreuses années
la Georgie en
fait demande
à s'intégrer dans l'Union européenne par
le BET de nombreux accords et cetera
mais quel est le rôle exactement de la
geéorgie est-ce que
l'adhésion dans l'UE permettrait à la
jgie de jouer un rôle important dans la
région des Caucases et de permettre
également d'aboutir à une résolution des
conflits est-ce que vous pensez que
votre adhésion permettrait également
d'agrandir l'ambition pour cette
régionl poures pour toutes ces questions
intéressantes je commencais par
euh répondre à la question de Monsieur
Juliani sur le choix du peuple euh en
effet le le choix européenne
l'intégration européenne c'est un choix
de la population geéorgienne et encore
récemment le l'opinion enfin le sondage
de l'opinion publique a montré que plus
de
80 5
% pour être plus exact 87 % de la
population geéorgienne soutient
fermément
euh l'intégration européenne et
euh c'est ce gouvernement d'ailleurs et
ce ce Parlement a inscrit dans la
Constitution
euh et c'était la volonté de du peuple
tout entier de de garantir cet axe de la
politique étrangère par la Constitution
donc c'est la Constitution qui prévoit
qui stipule que euh la priorité de la
politique étrangère de la Georgie est
l'intégration européenne intégration
euroatlantique maintenant
euh il faut comprendre ça comme une
commande de la de toute la population
quel que soit le parti politique qui
arrive au pouvoir ils seront euh ils
seront à l'écoute de cette commande du
peuple et ils ne peuvent pas dévier de
cette de cette politique qui qui a été
très euh rigoureusement prononcé et qui
a été inscrit dans la Constitution et
puis aussi euh si vous regardez les
événements politiques aucun autre sujet
politique ne peut faire
sortir une telle quantité de la
population dans la rue que quand il
s'agit de l'avenir européenne ou de de
réaffirmer euh son attachement et sa
fidélité à la politique européenne de la
Georgie après est-ce que c'est le choix
de des élites politiques aussi euh en
tant qu'ambassadeur je je peux vous dire
que à aucun moment je n'ai eu ni
recommandation ni conseil de
m'abstenir sur la politique européenne
ou sur le soutien de d'Ukraine ou bien
si je ne serais plus ambassadeur si on
m'avait demandé de soutenir des
résolutions ou des des des décisions qui
seraient plutôt pro russes ou
pour m'abstenir à sanctionner ou à pr à
être critique à l'égard de de la Russie
vous ne trouverez aucune décision et
aucune résolution que ça soit euh dans
les CADES bilatéral ou dans les casades
multilatéral que ça soit au Conseil de
l'Europe à l'os
euh à l'osde aussi mais que nous don
nous ne sommes pas membres nous ne
sommes que membres
observateur ou au Conseil de l'Europe la
Georgie a toujours soutenu euh
euh l'Ukraine ou des décisions
euh la Georgie s'est alignée à côté de
ses partenaires européenes et a toujours
voté contre la Russie d'ailleurs la
Georgie était un des initiateurs aussi
de ce mandat
d'arrêt de la Cour internationale pénale
de de la pour euh pour arrêter pour les
ses crimes monsieur Poutine donc un pays
Prusse n'oserait pas faire ça ça et
après on peut parler aussi d'une
certaine rétisence ou je dirais même
d'une prudence parfois qui peut être
interprété comme une extrême prudence
par rapport à la Russie parce
que ce gouvernement dit qu'il faut les
comprendre aussi parce qu'ils ont la
charge et la responsabilité de diriger
un pays qui a connu la guerre en 2008 et
qui ont qui ont également connu quel
était le degré de solidarité et le dgré
de de la protection de la communauté
internationale que nous
avons reçu tout en restant compréhensif
on connaît nous connaissons les le
contexte géopolitique et ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas une reproche à la communauté
internationale mais parfois on dit que
s'il y
avait au mois d'août 2008 une telle
mobilisation de la de l'opinion
internationale et de la communauté
internationale il n'y aurait peut-être
plus pas aussi rapidement la Crimée et
peut-être pas l'Ukraine aujourd'hui euh
donc la Georgie qui n'a aucune
protection pour l'instant on n'a pas de
parapluie ni de l'OTAN ni de l'Union
européenne et on est nous sommes
tributaaires de cette situation
géographique donc ce gouvernement pense
que il
faut pratiquer une politique de prudence
pour ne pas tomber dans les dans des
provocations russes répété tous les
jours il y a des provocations récemment
encore un de nos citoyens étaient tués
sur par le les forces d'occupation parce
qu'il a essayé d'ouvrir la porte que
qu'ils avaient la porte d'une église
qu'ils avaient condamné c'était il y
avait une fête religie religieuse il a
voulu allumer une sierge et il a été euh
non pas arrêté comme ça se passe euh
quasi quotidiennement euh ou kidnappé
mais il a été très sauvagement
abattu devant la porte de l'église euh
donc c'est pour dire que
euh c'est c'est une ce n'est pas du tout
une politique politique prorusse parfois
enfin pour laquelle il y a parfois des
reproches mais c'est surtout c'est la
volonté de pouvoir préserver une
stabilité dans le le pays c'est de de
pouvoir permettre aussi de développer
une économie nationale euh tout en
respectant les sanctions international
mais euh le gouvernement demande demande
à ses partenaires d'être plus
compréhensif euh puisque la Georgie n'a
pas introduit elle-même les sanctions
contre la Russie parce que sachant que
les sanction de la petite Georgie ne
ferait rien l'économie russe mais
l'inverse risquer d'étouffer d'asphyier
l'économie nationale déjà faible de du
pays et c'est toujours dans le
perspective de d'adhérer à l'Union
européenne qu'on avance par des petits
pas mais sûr pour parce que nous sommes
conscient aussi que l'Europe n' n'a pas
besoin d'encore d'une nouvelle guerre
dans notre région et donc on essayie
toujours en partenariat avec avec les
Européennes de de passer cette étape
très très tendue tout en gardant cette
stabilité et tout en restant aussi
fidèle de nos engagements par rapport
par rapport à l'Europe
euh
l'élargissement que nous que nous
entendons c'est c'estit en
effetlargissement géopolitique et les
Géorgiens trouvent que maintenant le le
temps est arrivé le jour est arrivé en
Europe où les les européennes comme
souvent dans le passé ils
doivent prendre des décisions sages et
clairvoyant euh sur fait touttin gardant
en tête les leçons du passé ce qui s
c'est d'où vient la Georgie la Moldavie
l'Ukraine dans quelle situation nous
nous trouvons actuellement et quel
serait quels seraient les conséquence
des décisions de refus ou
d'acceptation de ces pays au sein de de
l'Union européenne comme dans le passé
bon c'est ce n'est pas une euh vraiment
une excellente parallèle mais quand euh
l'Union européenne a décidé pour le
Portugal par exemple pour sauver le pays
de d'une dictature ou ou bien à l'égard
de de la Grèce ou ou de l'Espagne à
l'époque ces pays ne satisfaisaient pas
non plus ces fameux critères de
convergence mais il fallait prendre des
décisions politiques bon après je suis
conscient que je parle des pays
éminemment
européenes mais
aujourd'hui la question se pose aussi
de de prendre en compte ce contexte
géopolitique et de de prendre en compte
aussi de de prendre conscience aiste que
ces hommes et ces femmes politiques
européennes auront entre leurs mains euh
à décider le destin des pays le destin
des nations qui s'inspirent qui qui se
considèrent
comme membre de cette famille
culturellement la Georgie vous savez
c'est un c'est un Europe souvent c'est
en France qu'on entend la question se
poser est-ce que la Georgie c'est un
pays europ euréenne ou pas euh en
Georgie la question ne se pose même pas
bien sûr que nous sommes une culture
européenne et souvent Georg onim cité
Paul berie qui a donné les les critères
de qui quel espace géographique pourrait
prétendre appartenir à
l'Europe et il il a dit que tout tout
espace politique tout pays qui
prétendrait
appartenir à l'Europe devait
avoir l'influence de la culture
greco-romaine la religion chrétiennes et
les traditions démocratiques avec ces
ces trois critères la la Georgie
souscrit complètement euh et appartient
et nous avons enfin je pense que les
prétentions des Georgiens sont justifié
quand nous nous considérons que nous
sommes un pays un pays pays européenne
et euh oui
certes cette politique cette décision
sera géopolitique et certes c'est ce
sera un outil aussi de l'Union
européenne de s'affirmer davantage en
tant que puissance politique dans le
monde plein de chaos plein de défis et
que la Georgie de son côté
euh vous m'avez posé la question si
quels étaient les priorités les
programmes prioritaires naturellement la
la Georgie est tout à fait conscient de
ce qu'elle a aujourd'hui et de ce
qu'elle aimerait enfin de de quoi se
doter notamment de
d'avoir un système judiciaire beaucoup
plus enfin irréprochable euh plus plus
libre euh des réformes démocratiques qui
doteraient ce pays des outils de
développement euh et nous avons déjà un
marché et une politique économique qui
est très attractive si vous regardez les
classements euh internationaux c'est des
fait parce que souvent les les
diplomates les ambassadeurs ont tendance
à euh à présenter dans des ENF couleurs
rose et cetera mais vous pouvez vérifier
dans les classements internationaux la
geéorgie est parmi les premiers pays qui
ont réussi dans la lutte contre la
corruption dans la lutte fait pour la
réduction de de la BU buocratie la
geéorgie est parmi les les T premiers
pays à attirer les investissements et à
créer des conditions d'investissement
très
favorable nous sommes parmi les tout
premiers pays enfin le premier pays avec
la transparence budgétaire et le parmi
parmi les cinq premiers pays à où le
Doing Business c'est le plus facile
d'enregistrer d'enregistrer une
entreprise ne demande que quelques
quelques heures
et il y a des avantages fiscaux aussi
pour les investissement étrangers donc
c'est pour c'est pour se préparer parce
que la Georgie ne n'entend pas adhérer
et ne poser que des problèmes après au
sein de l'Union européenne et nous nous
avons
euh la possibilité
d'étudier les cas l'histoire et Georgie
essayie de d'être un partenaire digne et
euh
apporter les avantages naturellement et
euh pour pouvoir bénéficier après de la
protection sécuritaé ou pourquoi pas
bénéficier aussi de la prospérité que
économique qu'offre l'Union européenne
c'est ce ne sera pas dans un sens unique
dans le cas de la Georgie
euh et la G que la Georgie peut donner
c'est de de d'être fidèle aux valeurs
européennes et de d'être euh un
partenaire digne parce que quand on
quand on parle de notre volonté de
d'adhérer à l'Union européenne encore
une fois on arrive avec un Pact
d'engagement si parce que nous
sommes c'est c'est un c'est un peuple
responsable et nous savons que ce n'est
pas euh ce n'est pas uniquement euh
montrer une volonté une envie forte de
d'adhérer à l'Union européenne mais nous
savons que que derrière il y a euh il y
a des engagements à respecter il y a des
difficultés aussi qui nous qui nous
compliqueront aussi de dans la vie
quotidienne que ça soit au niveau
législative ou au niveau de l'exécutif
mais nous savons euh nous savons que ça
ça vaut la peine aussi de de faire des
efforts d'investir des efforts pour
pouvoir faire partie de ces euh de cette
famille euh et quel quels seraient les
les pays bon traditionnellement euh
c'était des pays les pays baltes la
Pologne qui était les locomotive pour la
Georgie euh euh aujourd'hui l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne est euh et il a la Hongrie
aussi qui qui
est qui soutient qui soutient la la
Georgie sur cette marche de l'Union
européenne mais nous avons de très
bonnes relations aussi avec avec des
avec d'autres pays de l'Union européenne
et concernant ce que peut offrir aussi
la Georgie à l'Union européenne puisque
la l'Union européenne s'intéresse de
plus en plus du du caucas du Sud et la
geéorgie qui qui a d'excellentes
relations avec les deux pays voisins de
de notre région euh a déjà jouer un rôle
positif dans la stabilisation de de la
région et dans l'avenir euh l'Union
européenne devrait prendre en même aussi
le destin de cette région parce que la
la Georgie ne soutient pas le format 3 3
+ 3 c'est-à-dire
euh l'Iran la Turquie la Russie
décida du sort de de notre région ce
n'est pas du tout dans les intérêts de
la Georgie et au contraire nous ne
voulons pas participer dans ce format de
négociation pour trouver une solution au
problème de notre région mais nous
appelons très fortement le l'Union
européenne la France en l'occurrence qui
a présidé le Groupe de Minsk euh et nous
leur demandons compter sur notre soutien
dans dans cette région mais venez il
faut que les Occidentaux prennent en
main parce que le une forme alternative
exclurait la participation de des forces
occidentales dans la résolution du
conflit du ha karabak par exemple alors
que la Georgie a du potentiel aussi pour
vous offrir de que la Georgie soit une
sorte de PL plateforme de négociation
euh encore récemment il y a moins de
mois la Georgie accueillait la
conférence de la grande route de la soie
et les deux dirigeants de l'Arménie et
de l'Azerbaïdjan était en Georgie et le
Premier ministre georgien avait
euh mené une conférence à laquelle les
deux assistaient et il tous les deux ont
euh confirmé également leur volonté de
poursuivre les négociations de paix et
pourquoi pas si euh la la paix revienne
dans cette région sous lesgide de de de
l'Union européenne la Georgie ne serait
que ravi de d'y
contribuer merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
pour ses réponses très très précises
j'ai donné maintenant la parole au
sénateurs alors il y a des commission
permanente qui se réunissent à 11h30 et
commission d'enquête donc il faut y
aller donc une minute chacun comme d'ab
madame de Sidrac pour le group pour les
rapporteurs élargissement et Didier
Marie tout de suite et ensuite Michel ve
merci président merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je serais très rapide je
voulais juste évoquer avec vous et vous
poser la question quelle est votre
relation aujourd'hui avec la Turquie
vous avez évoqué la Russie vous avez
évoqué évoqué évidemment l'Iran et
cetera juste à la fin de vos propos la
la Turquie qui on l'oublie parfois est
encore candidat hein donc je souhaitais
avoir un petit peu votre avis sur ce
point-là merci
Didier merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur le prérequis principal à
l'élargissement c'est le respect de
l'État de droit est-ce que vous pouvez
au-delà de ce que vous avez déjà annoncé
sur la lutte contre la corruption nous
dire ce qu'il en est de l'indépendance
de la justice de la fiabilité des
processus
électoraux de la liberté des médias
euh pour ce point et et et d'autres
par tout à l'heure l'un de nos experts a
évoqué le poids des oligarques dans le
pays et savoir s'ils étaient des freins
au rapprochement avec l'Union européenne
j'aurais aimé que vous puissiez nous
nous donner votre sentiment sur ce
sujet
euh monsieur Weber oui et puis Claude k
oui merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur j'ai un
peu le sentiment que le débat qu'on a ce
matin c'est un peu celui de l'
l'archpélisation à la fois territoriale
puisqu'il y a 20 % du territoire qui est
aujourd'hui euh qui pose question entre
l'OCI du Sud l'Abkhazie l'algéie donc je
voudrais savoir comment quel est
l'impact réel que cela a sur les
négociations qui qui peut y avoir mais
aussi finalement au sein même de de de
la politique de votre pays entre la
présidente et et le gouvernement en
place on a eu l'occasion d'en parler en
quoi cela permet effectivement de parler
d'une d'une seule voix et inf de la
population parce que je crois que même
s'il y a des soutiens qui sont des
soutiens extérieurs le principal sujet
c'est celui de la population qui adhère
finalement au fondement même de de
l'Europe et la façon dont puisque vous
faisiez état de de plus de 80 % de vos
concitoyens qui sont favorables à une
adhésion et comment est-ce que cette
population peut peser finalement sur le
destin de la Géorgie une une dernière
question il a beaucoup été question de
l'adhésion de la Finlande il y a
quelques mois à l'utant on en a pas trop
parlé ce matin quel était finalement les
leçons que vous en tiriez pour votre
votre pays puisque je crois que vous
vous êtes exprimé à ce sujet aussi merci
oui merci Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur alors je connais
relativement bien la situation de votre
pays puisque je suis rapporteur pour la
commission de suivi au niveau de
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe sur la Géorgie donc je vais pas
revenir sur les conflits gelés qui ont
une certaine incidence et qui avait une
certaine incidence sur pour la sur la
question de votre re candidature euh
autre point qui était un des freins
c'est l'extrême po polarisation
politique qui existe un autre frein
c'était la situation de votre ancien
président euh ça a été évoqué rapidement
et puis par contre j'ai noté avectis
avec beaucoup de satisfaction la
présentation de l'objectif de vos
réformes qui sont pas seulement pour
l'adhésion euh pour la candidature à
l'adhésion pardon mais également pour le
développement démocratique et le de
l'État de droit de de la Géorgie alors
parmi les 12 priorités qui vous avaient
été fixé il y en a une notamment qui
concerne la réforme globale de la
justice euh réforme que nous avions
proposé ainsi que la Commission de
Venise alors plusieurs petites réformes
ont été opérées vous savez que
l'adhésion de l'addition pardon de
plusieurs réformes ne correspond pas
forcément à une réforme globale quelle
que ça é demandé alors où on est la
réflexion à ce
niveau-là pour 5 minutes Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur d'accord je vais essayer
d'être pour la Turquie la Turquie est un
est un grand voisin de la
geéorgie historiquement nous n'avons pas
eu toujours de d'excellentes relations
de
voisinage l'Empire ottoman nous a nous a
visité ils sont sont restés pendant 3
siècles
naturellement la Géorgie la culture
geéorgienne est sorti enrichi de ce de
ces cultures parce que nous avons
toujours même les investissements
peuvent laisser des
traces positives si on ne regarde que du
côté positif de des
évasions mais aujourd'hui la Turquie est
un est un partenaire commerci et
stratégique pour la Géorgie la Turquie
étant un pays membre de l'OTAN nous aide
aussi pour l'entraînement de nos
militaires et la la Turquie est un est
un des
allié fidèle aussi pour soutenir
l'avancement dans l'intégration à l'OTAN
de la
Georgie et c'est un et naturellement la
Georgie est intéressée à ce que la
démocratie soit et que le la Turquie
soit un état de de droit euh
naturellement parce que vous savez que
bon il y a ce partenariat mais il y a
aussi dans les perspectif naturellement
pour pour la geéorgie tout intérêt de de
notre pays et que la Turquie reste un
pays démocratique est stable parce que
puiss
euh sinon naturellement la la Georgie
euh risque d'avoir d'autres soucis
sécuritaires aussi si cette région
n'était pas n'était pas stable
euh concernant concernant le respect des
des médias
euh l'État de droit en geéorgie
euh la Georgie
a n'a pas n'a pas dévieré de cette euh
de cette voie de d'être fidèle de l'État
de droit et que la
suprématie la supériorité et l'égalité
de tous devant le droit est un principe
euh fondamental d'ailleurs la question
du de notre ancien si pour pour relier
cette la réponse de l'ancien président
qui qui purge une peine aujourd'hui euh
pour tout vous dire ayant
travaillé j'étais son conseiller j'ai
été numéro 2 à l'ambassade à son époque
naturellement je suis j'ai été fier
aussi de représenter la Georgie à
l'époque des grandes réformes
démocratiques de l'européanisation et
cetera mais après euh vous savez il y a
eu il y a eu des procès le la justice
avait des des cas concrets il y a eu des
une partie de la population qui s'était
senti laésé malheureusement avec tout ce
que avec tout le positif que je pourrais
dire de de l'époque où quand il était
Président je ne peux pas me substituer à
la justice et que
euh il y a une demande aussi euh de
l'État de droit aussi de l'égalité de
euh devant de tous devant de la droit
euh et bon il était il était en Ukraine
il était exilé en Ukraine il était
recherché par la justice en
Georgie malheureusement il a décidé de
revenir en Georgie avec un projet
politique euh son projet n'a pas marché
donc la révolution n'a pas eu lieu euh
il
ne il y il y avait il n'y avait pas un
tel soutien qu'il lesctait que tout
toute la Georgie sortirait dans la rue
et cetera bon malheureusement c'est
comme ça il est il
est il est prisonnier aujourd'hui bon il
n'est pas en prison parce que pour des
raisons de sa santé parce qu'il a entamé
une grève de fa qu'il a qu' a conduit à
l'hôpital il est dans un
hôpital
privé où il où il reçoit des soins
médicaux il il a il reçu plus de 2000
visites dans sa chambre d'hôpital et
maintenant récemment il a il a déclaré
qu'il revenait dans la qu'il prendrait
la tête de de son parti politique et
qu'il s'engagerait plus
activement dans la politique pour se
préparer pour les élections
2024 parce que dans son parti politique
euh donc il y a eu une une sorte de
émiêement donc il y a plusieurs groupes
qui se sont créés politiques au sein de
de son parti
euh le poids des oligarques en Georgie
c'est une des c'est une des
recommandation en effet la
déoligarchisation et c'était sur cette
recommandation la
Georgie déjà au début ont
cherchait quelle était la notion de
oligarque qui qui était oligarque puce
qu'on a selon la Commission de Venise la
Georgie a pris comme exemple modèle le
modèle ukrainien de de la loi des
oligarches oligarques et du coup avec ce
ce modèle il y aurait plusieurs
oligarques y compris ceux qui dirigent
l'opposition en ce moment
donc souvent euh même si je ne voulais
pas le le citer souvent on ne parle
d'une de la même personne en Georgie qui
qui est fondateur du parti au pouvoir en
ce moment mais
euh très honnêtement vous ne vous ne
l'entendrez pas publiquement enfit
depuis plusieurs années il est il est
euh il s'est retiré de la politique
complètement et après pour chercher
quelque part s'il y a une influence sur
des décisions politiques ou moi
personnellement je je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas parce que bon il est comme le
fondateur du parti il a peut-être un
certain une certaine influence sur les
hommes et femmes politiques qui sont
dans la politique mais il
n'interviennent pas depuis plusieurs
années depuis qu'il a quitté la
politique il il n'est plus dans la
politique actuelle
euh concernant les territoires la
Georgie est conscient aussi de de
ces pour les oligarques selon une des
définitions
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont plus d'un
million de euros et qui ont une
influence sur les
médias dans ce cas j'ai peur que dans
beaucoup de pays européennes il y aura
aussi des personnes qui qui peuvent
avoir C ce même statut
d'oligarques je pense que euh je
pense que parfois on ne en cherchant le
problème
euh on oublie que il faut il faut il
vaudrait peut-être mieux euh critiquer
et appeler à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
dérapage dans la politique à ce que les
réformes soient soient menées à bien et
que les réformes soi soit soit bien
réalisé parce que sinon autrement on ne
on aura que des soupçons et quand on
nous demande mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
concret
euh mais mais très sincèrement sachez
que fait l'ambassadeur que je suis je
suis extrêmement embarrassé souvent par
cette question parce que moi je ne le
vois pas je ne
euh je je ne sais pas s'il a vraiment
une une vraie influence sur la le
pouvoir décisionnel peut-être puisque
c'est le pays qui l' créé qui est au
pouvoir en ce moment mais lui il a dit
qu'il se retirerait qu'il
laissait donc une équipe
dirigeant à gouverner le
pays et après bon souvent dans la
critique où je rencontre les
journalistes et cetera souvent son nom
revient lui que qu'est-ce qu'il devient
qu'est-ce qu'il fait je ne sais pas
je très honnêtement je ne je ne vois pas
ces traces directes d'action euh sur la
politique actuelle euh sur les les
territoire actuellement occupé par la
force occupant russes euh nous nous
avons nous adoptons cette politique de
la réintégration par la confiance
c'est-à-dire la Georgie européenne plus
la geéorgie
développera économiquement politiquement
euh même maintenant euh avec les outils
que nous donne l'accord de l'association
le rapprochement le libre échange et
cetera nous proposons à ces ces pays de
de profiter de tout ce bien que l'Europe
nous propose et dans l'avenir euh la
Géorgie européenne euh sera déjà une
réponse à ces populations pour pour
qu'il fasse le choix soit qu'il reste
euh dans un pays
fantô euh gouverné pratiquement par la
Russie par la Russie corrompue par la
Russie imprévisible et ou ou bien
choisir euh de faire partie de avec un
statut
naturellement avec la plus grande
autonomie que la geéorgie leur propose
mais à l'intérieur de l'État
geéorgien et c'est c'est le choix qu'a
fait la geéorgie de ne pas rourir à la
force y compris maintenant parce que la
Russie la Russie laissait circuler les
rumeurs comme quoi la Georgie voulait et
aimerait récupérer ses territoires par
la force en profitant de la situation en
Ukraine en ouvrant le 2e front et le
gouvernement a envoyé les signaux plutôt
pacifiques dire qu'il n'y aurait pas il
n'y aurait pas de tentative de
récupération par la force de ces
territoirees concernant
le le problème en ce moment qui qui
existe entre entre notre présidente
et le gouvernement le problème est
plutôt de l'ordre interne naturellement
euh la présidente qui est qui est
française européenne et cetera elle sait
comment on parlerit aux européennes elle
porte le message euh le message de la
Georgie européenne à l'étranger et je
pense que c'est euh c'est malentendu
serait plutôt
par je dirais ni plutôt par la jalousie
mais par le le gouvernement aimerait
mener ce flambau lui-même euh parce que
euh et crois que la présidente
vol euh
la vedette comme comme on dit parce que
c'est aujourd'hui malheureusement la la
présidente n'a plus des attribution que
l'institution du président avait avant
euh la politique étrangère est menée y
compris par le gouvernement et comme
souvent il n'y a pas de de concertation
entre la présidente et le
gouvernement le gouvernement trouve que
au moins il de vait être mis au courant
quand elle part effectuer des visites à
l'étranger qua apporté des messages très
importants pour le pays c'est c'est ça
en fait cette ce processus de
destitution n'était pas n'était pas
censé aboutir destittu un président ce
serait ça donnerait une très mauvaise
image de du pays mais comme le
gouvernement pensait que comme elle
n'écoute personne à l'intérieur du pays
au moins un organe constitutionnel le le
plus compétent pourrait lui déterminer
les lignes rouges euh ou jusqu'où si euh
euh mais bon vous me verrez un
ambassadeur très heureux si on n'avait
pas ce cette image et ce souci de
l'étranger naturellement enfin moi étant
européenne convaincu moi je je
préconiseraai même dès le début d'avoir
comme ambassadrice ou présidente porter
ce flambau européen à l'étranger mais
euh vous savez ici euh puisque la
Georgie réussit bien sur ce ce processus
le gouvernement euh veut aussi montrer
sa participation c'est moi et euh voilà
c'est les deux on a ce luxe dans le pays
on a une toute une compétition entre le
la présidence et le gouvernement qui est
plus europé merci Monsieur merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur on va devoir
clore nos débats parce que comme je le
disaisés mais c'est très bien oui oui
bon on pas s sans se voir euh merci à
tous en tout cas de de ce de ce beau
temps d'échange en tout cas sur un
format un peu innovant mais je vous
l'accorde mais qui est qui est très
intéressant à la fois expert et
politique même si j'ai noté que les
experts savaient parler politique merci
à tous et bonne bonne journée merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup excellente
journée
on est obligé d'cter il y a il y a des
commissions permanentes à
11h avec grand
PLA